tous et bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
sur rt france pour cette journée
particulière journée de la victoire
journée à du 9 mai le jour de la
victoire justement des alliés sur
l'allemagne nazie en 1945 et dispositifs
actionner exceptionnel vous allez
vouloir tout au long de cette journée
sur les antennes verte et france on va
vous faire vivre en direct toutes les
festivités à commencer par le célèbre
défilé militaire alors avant de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet vous vous demandez
certainement pourquoi la russie célèbre
la capitulation allemande le 9 mai et
non le 8 comme chez de mon france et
bien c'est tout simplement une histoire
de décalage horaire l'acte de
capitulation a été signé à berlin le 8
mai 1945 à 23h01 il était 0 1h01 pardon
une heure du matin à moscou
et puis vous l'entendez 1,7 cloches qui
sonnent en ce moment même du côté de
moscou c'est le signe que cette parade
militaire va commencer dans quelques
instants ou par tout de suite en direct
à moscou
[Musique]
à
c'est pour saluer notre info de la
fédération de russie est l'étendard de
la victoire garde à vous salut à gauche
présentait
[Musique]
la place et j'ai vu des filles
prénationale de la fédération pour
inaugurer les sens large
105e édition second est devenu le
symbole d'un film à sa victoire
si monsieur charmant
16ème album bonjour c'est sûr de toi grh
d'accenture
[Musique]
milon
pumain
risqué l'hermine teachers
il est écrasé
la victoire va mal et à lui
si vous dire aujourd'hui le drapeau les
plus rares de la victoire
conforté par les meilleurs des
militaires ni facilement une probité les
sergents entourent sergent
[Musique]
sous les yeux les communes maxime
malakoff et alexei routière
[Musique]
les premiers jours de la guerre des
centaines de milliers de volontaires
partir au front me défendre leur terre
natale contre les envahisseurs nazis
leur héroïsme et leur vaillance dans la
défense de brest
odessa sébastopol et smolensk tout l'art
leningrad mot script stalingrad mirent
fin au projet de destruction réclère
dominion ce métier
[Musique]
leurs noms sont inscrits pour toujours
dans la cause de la victoire grâce aux
efforts accomplis par les arrières par
leur labeur dévoués dans les délais les
plus brefs
il pu rétablir la production
industrielle et assurer
l'approvisionnement en armes et
équipements nécessaires à l'armée rouge
[Musique]
les héritiers des soldats de la victoire
et le peuple russe dans son ensemble
salut l'étendard de la victoire et les
vétérans de la grande guerre patriotique
qui libérèrent la patrie et les pays
d'europe de la peste brune
[Musique]
au repos
ce
alors
hugo
le défilé garde à vous salut à gauche
présentait
[Musique]
les troupes fret a déchiré son passé en
revue par le général d'armée sergueï
choïgou ministre de la défense de la
fédération de russie au son de la marche
militaire le général phùng huu se dirige
vers le centre de la place rouge pour
entendre le compte rendu de l'état du
dispositif
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre de la défense
les troupes de la garnison de moscou
sont prêtes pour le défilé en l'honneur
du 66e anniversaire de la victoire
[Musique]
générale c'est le kof
j'aimais
valady
le ministre de la défense commence le
passage en revue des troupes du défilé
[Musique]
chez vous
le général sergueï choïgou va saluer les
troupes terrestres
[Musique]
c'était le ministre de la défense
adresse un message de félicitations aux
troupes rassemblées sur la place rouge
[Musique]
vichy s'installe
les effectifs des troupes terrestres
poursuivent le perfectionnement de leurs
aptitudes au combat ils s'instruisent
pour maîtriser les nouveaux types
d'armements et d'équipements militaires
leurs modalités dans tournée
[Musique]
les troupes terrestres continue à jouer
un rôle majeur en matière de sécurité et
de défense des intérêts de la russie
[Musique]
on s'est dit allez on se lève à 6h et
wagashis n'est pas dû à des unités
achetées sur itunes et moyens
[Musique]
6 2
la ministre de la défense a salué les
forces aérospatiale les pilotes des
forces l'aérospatiale les militaires de
la défense anti aérienne et des troupes
spatiales du livre au cours
d'inspections surprises et de leur
mission de veille permanente ont fait
preuve d'un niveau élevé de leur
disponibilité à remplir leur mission de
défense de l'espace aérien et extra
atmosphérique du pays
[Musique]
re c'est du aulas
[Applaudissements]
wakata qui n'est pas des vérités at-elle
témoigné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le ministre de la défense vient de
saluer les détachements du district
militaire ouest des unités de
transmission et de la police militaire
de la garde nationale et le ministère
des situations d'urgence
c'était dur
[Applaudissements]
pause les os cindy c'est triste kadhafi
n'est pas bien des vérités à justin
manière
[Musique]
ministre de la défense a salué en
mémoire de la vistoire les détachements
des troupes aéroportées et des unités du
génie milieu défense nbc de missiles
stratégiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oiseaux d'eau
c'est triste kadhafi n'est pas des
vérités at elle est une des manières
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le ministre de la défense a salué les
détachements de la marine du fsb service
fédéral de sécurité
suivent les troupes ferroviaire des
cosaques les femmes militaires et des
jeunes élèves des écoles militaires
souvorov machine off et des cadets de la
marine ainsi que des membres du
mouvement
john arne riise
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce sont plus de 12 mille
militaires qui participent aux défilés
gerin
le général sergueï choïgou a terminé de
passer les troupes en revue et va rendre
coup au président de la fédération de
russie commandant en chef des forces
armées russes vladimir poutine
[Musique]
aussi glacé
[Applaudissements]
jimmy choo continent
[Musique]
alors je suis retourné doit notamment de
chine hu jun émission à mes frais c'est
ce qu'elle fait dans l'axé ouais ce que
parce qu est-ce qu on gagne et on n'a
pas de gâteau ministre à bordeaux n'est
dit nulle part mais chago au repos
[Musique]
or j'ai aimé glh devenir et si chers
citoyens de russie vis des rames chers
anciens combattants il m'a trop ses
camarades soldats et matelots
sous-officiers officiers mariniers
attire ses camarades officiers généraux
amiraux bonne fête de la victoire 7-2
signifie qu'une signification historique
très importante pour l'ensemble du monde
constitue d'une fête qui a été est et
sera toujours pour la russie pour notre
peuple russe une fête sacrée à juste
titre c'est la victoire sur cet ennemi
qui était le nazisme et qui a laissé une
marque de 10 pour toutes les générations
et nous vénérons l'héroïsme de ce qu'ils
ont vaincu une chaire anciens
combattants nous inclinons devant votre
force devant votre voyance votre
cohésion et votre amour de la patrie que
vous avez montré que ce n'est
qu'ensemble que nous pouvons parvenir à
ce qui semblait impossible
vous avez surmonté cet ennemi vous
l'avait vaincu vous avez était prêt à
sacrifier vos enfants tout ça pour
sauver la patrie et c'est une victoire
incontestable qui sera saluée dans les
siècles
cette date restera historique le 9 mai
1945 nous nous souviendrons toujours de
l'importance de cet exploit accompli par
le peuple soviétique
les batailles les plus décisives pour
l'issue de la guerre
notre peuple s'est montrée unie magath
rhône
juni mot à dire dans cette voie
d'abnégation dur et de dévouement
merci est sur tous les fronts bien dans
tous les combats les plus âpres en sur
terre en mer dans les airs
défendant cette fois cette fois en la
valeur de la terre natale
que ce soit sur les marches de l'article
ou sur les marches des montagnes du
caucase à ti sur le franchissement des
grandes rivières du nieppe kita nul et
c'est là le peuple russe a défendu les
populations civiles a défendu les fils
héroïques de moscou edenred à l'époque
de kiev de kertch stalingrad smolensk
nouveau récit et cette cohésion entre le
front et les arrières et apporter ce
qu'il fallait pour assurer cette
victoire et les usines de l'oral de
sibérie ont travaillé en kazakhstan et
dans d'autres républiques d'asie
centrale
les efforts vont continuer au niveau
industriel
les peuples se sont prêts se sont
montrés prêts à verser leur sang pour
sauver la patrie
aujourd'hui nous rendons hommage et nous
exprimons notre gratitude a cru que la
génération de ses héros de la guerre
le garde en mémoire la vaillance et le
courage des prairies dg héros moquer
judée le garde en mémoire cette douleur
contre ce qui ne passe pas ce qu'ils la
douleur des camps de concentration la
douleur et des villages détruits dans
les territoires occupés durcir et nous
garde en mémoire tous ceux qui ont perdu
la vie dans cette guerre
thierry c'est la mémoire des fils
mortiers chi des pères dire de les
maires mouge les grands-parents jaune
dès mardi
des femmes des frères des soeurs tue des
camarades de régiment brouiller des
proches des amis gardent en mémoire ce
qui nous ont quittés mais notamment
actuelle je déclare une minute de
silence
bergin aux ir chers amis
vous êtes un beau cadeau et spawn yates
oui si tu lis matière la ville x cette
année voit ça fait 80 ans que cette
guerre mondiale a commencé jeudi cette
grande guerre patriotique et le 22 juin
1941 est une des dates les plus
tragiques de l'histoire de la russie
l'ennemi à jour à gré c'est notre terre
il est venu sur notre terre pour semer
la douleur la mort l'horreur et des
souffrances une insupportable
il ne voulait pas seulement éliminé les
structures politiques le système
soviétique mais que nous détruire et
détruire en tant qu' en tant qu'etat en
tant que nation et effacés de la surface
de la terre cpt
la russie est grosse
cette menace est devenu a constitué un
élan pour l'ensemble de la population
des peuples de russie résister contre
eux cette cet ennemi et le peuple
soviétique s'est levé s'est souvenu de
son serment à libérer les pays d'europe
italie tu paies de du jour en se
souvenant de la force et de la puissance
de notre armée et du courage de
l'abnégation et futurs des mères et des
épouses qui ont laissé partir ceux qui
ne sont pas toujours revenu mais cette
mémoire restera longtemps et maubeuge et
une autre esprit au cours des siècles
rendre hommage aussi à tout le personnel
médical et qui a sauvé les bleus ses
marronniers qui a fait tout son possible
que sur le front
pour jude sauver ceux qui avaient été
touchés cette guerre qui a été la plus
sanglante qui a frappé aussi bien les
jeunes générations une touche de
nombreux radiers les soumettre donc
cette guerre a apporté tant douleur tant
de malheurs qu'il est impossible dont
deux justifiés ou de pardonner ce qui
s'était laissé aller à 28,17 voyait sur
régime des monstre nazi prendre de
l'ampleur au coeur de l'europe avec
l'antisémitisme la xénophobie
tout cela devait être arrêté il fallait
mettre fin à cette guerre et l'histoire
nous oblige à tirer des conclusions à
tirer des leçons mais où nous constatons
que tous ne sont pas prêts à tirer cette
conclusion qui veulent en à nouveau
défendre cette idéologie on voit la
ligne 1802 d'extrémistes et de cette
idéologie de volonté voit cette volonté
de réécrire l'histoire
les centaines de milliers de morts sont
ignorés par ce genre aujourd'hui on sait
que chaque famille garde la mémoire de
ceux qui sont combattus la russie
continue à défendre le droit
international et le continuerons à
défendre en même temps nos intérêts nos
intérêts nationaux
et vaillantes forces armées sont prêtes
à défendre la sécurité et les intérêts
de la russie en faveur du développement
et de la prospérité des familles et de
nos vétérans leur destin des exemples
pour l'unité c'est un modèle à suivre et
que nous on doit vers lequel nous devons
tendre qui passent beaucoup et on a
juste dit oui jean aux affaires réussite
future
saluons la gloire du peuple russe
[Musique]
heureuse fête de la victoire à tous quoi
m
[Musique]
défilé khartoum où paraît au défi les
bataillons garder la distance
le premier bataillon tous trois les
autres à droite droite larmes sur
l'épaule à droite alignement
en avant marche
[Musique]
c'est le début du défilé des troupes à
pied le défilé est placée sous les
ordres du général d'armée oleg salenko
va
[Musique]
grâce mai prochain du beau-fils sur la
place rose les jeunes musiciens de
l'école de musique rai de musique
militaire du ministère russe de la
défense qui porte le nom de valérie kahl
elop ajoutant que la compagnie d'honneur
et sous les ordres du colonel alexandre
guerassimova commandant l'école de
musique militaire
les jeunes musiciens de la compagne de
tambours ouvre le défilé solennelle des
troupes dans neuf le rythme alger le pas
de marche aux unités qui défilent mis
mon plus beau devant les tribunes
défiler les porte-drapeaux de l'étendard
de la victoire du drapeau national de la
fédération de russie de l'étendard des
forces armées russes les porte-drapeaux
sont accompagnées de la compagnie de la
garde d'honneur du tout sans 54e
régiment photo nombre de commandements
que le régime ont dit preobrazhensky
[Musique]
la place rouge a créé les standards
historiques de combat des unités ayant
été décorés pendant la guerre de l'orge
d'alexandre nevski odieux les héritiers
de leurs exploits participe aujourd'hui
aux défilés
c'est beaucoup dans le détachement
d'honneur cette année nous célébrons
d'ailleurs les 800 en tant que chef de
choeur et défenseur de la vieille russie
le prince alexandre nevsky du trot de
mascouche c'est maintenant au tour d'une
compagnie de l'école militaire souvent
hors de moscou de défiler devant les
tribunes le commandement du colonel igor
et qui mauvaise élève de l'école sont
des participants incontournable des
défilés de la victoire à vos futurs sur
la place rouge
les élèves de l'école militaire ce
l'europe de l'est billeter à chaud le
détachement d'honneur et sous les ordres
du colonel igor kozo d'ayem en 1943
l'école a accueilli ses premiers élèves
marqué par le destin des armes
il devint pour un leur maison natale est
une école de vie
sur les pavés de la place rouge je vous
voyez un détachement d'honneur et élèves
de l'école nakhimov de saint pétersbourg
sous les ors du contre-amiral j'suis
alexandre pau pauvre chef de l'école
ce maillot sur la place rouge je vous
voyais défiler de jeunes marins du corps
de cadets de marine de cronstadt en tête
du détachement d'honneur
le capitaine de vaisseau nicolas doze
besco rue du commandant le corps de
cadets dans les murs de cet
établissement sont reprises les
meilleures traditions d'instruction des
cadets de la marine des fils maintenant
un détachement des meilleurs
représentants du mouvement paramilitaire
et patriotique
yuna mia qui signifie jeune armée sous
le commandement de daria borisova où je
suis ce mouvement regroupe dans quel
pays plus de 2 800 mille jeunes garçons
et filles actives mais qui témoignent de
durenque asmar actifs
[Musique]
louches sur la place rouge régiment
d'être au terrestre des forces armées de
russie leur marché est offerte par était
officier en cours de formation à
l'académie interarmes des forces armées
de la fédération de russie
le détachement d'honneur et sous les
ordres du général alexandre romanes kg
occupé 24 commandants de groupes
d'armées et plus de 80 chefs d'armée
compte assumer les larves un chrono dans
les murs de cette académie le 2ie mille
anciens élèves de cet établissement
prestigieux sont devenues veuves héros
de l'union soviétique créé héros de la
fédération de russie
[Musique]
moue devant les tribunes défile un
détachement de l'université militaire du
ministère de la défense de la fédération
de russie ce les autres du général
vladimir lougovoï commandant
l'université du royaume l'université
c'est le principal établissement
militaire d'enseignement supérieur à
l'orientation humanitaire qui forme des
spécialistes dans les disciplines
politique au bout du cycle logique
juridique traduction interprétation en
matière militaire à plus de 300 héros de
l'union soviétique de la russie en sont
issus il a ensuite solennellement sur la
place aux jeunes l'académie militaire
relève des tendances et de matériel son
dépassement toner est commandée par le
général vladimir font nova loeb
dans la guerre les diplômés de
l'académie ont participé aux préparatifs
et au déroulement de toutes les
opérations stratégiques au niveau des
groupes d'armées et désarmé
la place rouge a créé les élèves de
l'académie militaire de défense
antiaérienne maréchal wasilewski
le détachement d'honneur et sur les
autres du général gleb et rumine
commandant l'académie oui oui oui durant
les années de la guerre les hommes de la
défense contre avions accomplir des
missions consistant à repousser les
attaques l'aviation ennemie
aujourd'hui l'académie forme st80
supérieur pour les systèmes et complexes
deux missiles sol air
[Musique]
je suis des filets souvent ce qu'était
ce effectifs féminins et cet abaissement
d'enseignement militaire supérieur de
russie ce sont des futurs officiers de
l'intendance les psychologues et sa
retraite militaire juriste responsable
financier huit officiers des forces et
sert spatiale était transmission et sont
placés sous les ordres du commandant
maria vassilieva et du capitaine
svetlana ici cobas aujourd'hui on compte
plus de 40 mille femmes dans les rangs
de l'armée russe
devant les tribunes et des films
maintenant régiment des forces 0
spatiale russe
il comprend des officiers et des élèves
de l'académie aérospatiale choco ski et
gagarine sur le détachement d'honneur et
sur les autres tout général au ghana qui
gît propre commandant l'académie tout en
sentant d'histoire cette académie a
formé plus de 1500 officiers
qui ont été décorés ne la plus haute
distinction à savoir le titre de héros
de l'union soviétique et de la
fédération de russie
cette année la russie a célébré le 60e
anniversaire du premier vol habité dans
l'espace en l'occurrence de youri
gagarine qui étaient diplômés de cette
académie
l'académie a apporté une contribution
considérable à la conquête de l'espace
elles forment aujourd'hui des officiers
dans diverses spécialités appliquée
allait bien sûr militaires et aux
troupes de guerre électronique sur la
place rouge
un détachement d'honneur de l'académie
spatiales militaires à morges à skis qui
est placée sous les ordres du général
maxime penkova directeur de l'académie
ces diplômes sont ces diplômés pardon
sont des ingénieurs de pointe qui sont
affectés dans les troupes spatiales
aujourd'hui l'académie est le principal
établissement de formation et de
recherche pour les spécialistes
fusée spatiale
vous voyez maintenant ils me régis
montée forces navales de la fédération
de russie
voyons ce passage commencer par
détachement d'honneur tout marin de
l'académie navale à meyrals kuznetsova
ce détachement et placés sous les ordres
du capitaine de vaisseau andré limengo
diplômé de l'académie composent
l'essentiel du commandement de la marine
russe le de trente anciens diplômés qui
sont devenus héros de l'union soviétique
et les terreaux du travail socialiste
immobile ou sur la place route des
élèves de l'école supérieure navale à
meyrals nakhimov de la mer noire qui est
basée à sébastopol où ils défilent sous
les autres du contre-amiral alexandrie
look évite le devin mais l'officier de
marine
ils sont issus de cet institut depuis et
parmi plus de 20 sont du héros de
l'union soviétique et lire aussi de la
fédération de russie
pour ne pas rajouter devant les tribunes
était-il l'infanterie de marine qui est
représenté par 60 heures unique et mme
bricq à décrire canesse défend tories de
marine de la flotte du nord dont le
détachement est commandé par le
lieutenant-colonel evans au lot qui lie
la génération actuelle des soldats de
l'infanterie de marine poursuit les
pleureuses tradition de défense de la
région arctique de la russie
le défilé se poursuit avec les troupes
de missiles stratégiques
le détachement d'honneur et sous les
ordres du général andré morozova
il comprend des officiers et des élèves
officiers des cours supérieures des
établissements d'enseignement militaire
tétreault plus de missiles stratégiques
notamment l'académie militaire pierre
legrand et sa filiale de la ville de
surf au cover qui fête cette année ses
connaissances et les compétences
assimilé dans les meubles d'académie
permettent aux officiers des troupes de
missiles stratégiques de remplir leur
mission de défense des intérêts
nationaux de la russie
les diplômés de cet établissement sont
des spécialistes unique en matière
d'exploitation de tous les types de
missiles stratégiques notamment de
complexes billard ce mobile est
stationnaire
voici
[Musique]
des militaires des troupes aéroportées
mais vous frappe fièrement de sol de
leur pas martial le détachement de
l'école supérieure générale marguelov de
commandement aéroporté deriaz année et
sous les ordres de son commandant le
colonel russe l'anzhi evdokimov je pense
qu'il est diplômé de cet établissement
figurent parmi les meilleurs dans
l'armée russe sur leur niveau
d'instruction
vous voyez maintenant défilé le 330 une
game régiment de parachutistes de la
garde de la ville de kostroma qui
appartient à la 98e division aéroportée
le détachement d'honneur et sous les
ordres du colonel au legs mais le
régiment est le premier dans l'armée
russe à s'être vu remettre le titre
prestigieux de régiments de force de
frappe
la marche se poursuit avec l'institut de
protection des frontières
le détachement et sur les autres que
générale valérie kozlov commandant
l'institut aujourd'hui dans ses rangs
servent des petit fils et arrière petit
fils des gardes frontières qui figurent
les premiers à faire face à l'offensive
de l'agresseur dans les tout premiers
jours de la guerre un choc du cross med
sur la place rouge se défilent des
militaires de la 45e pris 4 u ceni de la
gare de berlin
le détachement d'honneur et placés sous
les ordres du colonel romane véhicules
ce qui dieu grâce au génie militaire
des dizaines d'opérations de défense
passive ont été menées à bien au cours
de la seconde guerre mondiale sur la
place rouge je vouvoyais maintenant
défilé du détachement de l'académie
maréchal timoshenko de protection
nucléaire bactériologique et chimique
j'suis au détachement est commandée par
le général igor email
bousculés diplômés de cette académie
serbe
aujourd'hui investir en régiment des
forces armées
[Musique]
le détachement des transmissions des
fils représenté par le décès lève de
l'académie militaire maréchal beau
johnny et laisse les ordres du général
et sergei costard eve commandant
l'académie depuis plus de 100 ans
l'histoire le module chantant histoire
n'a qu'à des méformes des commandants et
des ingénieurs jours profitent des
unités de transmission de l'armée russe
ainsi que pour les forces armées de 40
pays étrangers
grâce ni bouche devant les tribunaux
vous voyez vous défilez bataillon d'être
au ferroviaire
elles sont représentés par 300 8e
brigade ferroviaire sous les ordres du
colonel igor orlov son commandant deux
cent soixante dix ans
les spécialistes en transport a mis les
terres ferroviaire rempli les missions
les plus complexes dans les délais les
plus courts bruns et pour plus qu'au
niveau citoyen sur la place se défile un
détachement teneur de la police
militaire sous les ordres du lieutenant
colonel vitality calvario aujourd'hui la
police militaire accompli tin man
d'émissions spéciales notamment dans
d'autres pays sur la place principale du
pays des files a voulu un détachement
d'honneur de l'académie de sécurité
civile du ministère des situations
d'urgence ce détachement d'honneur et
placés sous les ordres du général victor
pantchenkov comment dans l'académie
partout dans le monde les anciens élèves
de l'académie sont reconnus comme parmi
les meilleurs en matière d'intervention
sur l'eagle sur deux catastrophes et de
sauvetage de vies
vous voyez passer détachement de la
division autonome mesure chinsky des
troupes de la garde nationale de la
fédération de russie qui est commandée
par le général tu maîtrises cher et
panneaux dits commandant la division
le pire au monde depuis les défilés de
1940 un binôme les militaires de la
division partait au front pour défendre
moscou qui en juin 45 il se taire devant
le mausolée blaise étendard et les
drapeaux préoccupé unité nazie écrasé
l'astuce société des cosaques de russie
est représentée par détachement
d'honneur des troupes de cosaques de
copan et de la grande troupe sud ont
dirigé par le général kozak nicolet dolo
d'âge pendant des centaines d'années les
faux sacs ont défendu le pays natal
conquis de nouveaux territoires et
protéger les frontières
aujourd'hui la tradition kozak se
poursuit la jeune génération est éduqué
dans l'esprit du service à la russie
nous suivent sur la place rouge étaient
filés des sommes du district mais les
terres rouges est avec à leur tête un
détachement d'honneur de la
2e division d'infanterie mécanisée cas
les mines de taman ayun placés sous les
ordres du général sarrail m et dave
cette division connu son baptême de feu
en juin 1940 un chiche dans la défense
de la ville de smolensk pour l'héroïsme
a généralisé de ses hommes
la division fut une des premières à être
distingué du titre prestigieux de la
division de la garde ses soldats
libérèrent le caucase du nord
les crimes et les pays baltes douce et
la prusse orientale durant la guerre 34
fusiliers furent déclarés héros de
l'union soviétique et cinq chevaliers à
part entière de l'ordre de la gloire
toutes classes sur la place les
militaires de la 4e division blindée de
la carte entre pauvres mais le
commandant de la division le
général-major plati mersa vaz qui est en
tête de la formation durant la seconde
guerre mondiale ce groupe d'armées s'est
illustré dans les combats dans la région
et doit obtenir l'appellation
honorifique mais quand amy rose sky a
durant la guerre
les chartes les divisions ont parcouru
le chemin des combats de voronej à
prague les étendards de ses unités
porter 23 décoration de congrès a suivi
du site et lui un fort datant de
soixante dix ans unit ce célèbre
division et les cosaques
oui milliers de soldats qui sont issus
de la communauté des cosaques absolument
servi dans ces unités
[Musique]
sur la place rouge se défile la 27e
brigade d'infanterie mécanisée de
sébastopol avec à sa tête le colonel où
ils trient axionova commandant la
brigade de la guerre les soldats de la
brigade participé à la libération de
l'ectrims et et des pays baltes
mais pourvu treize militaires de la
brigade ont obtenu les plus hautes
distinctions du pays
deux héros de l'union soviétique et
l'hérault de la fédération de russie 2
son chevalier de l'ordre de la gloire
[Musique]
purge le défilé d'être pamiers s'achève
par le passage des élèves fisc et de
l'école supérieur interarmées de moscou
un but l'officier qui défilent en tête
où est le lieutenant-colonel batîment
issa kovalchuk et économie les terres a
été créé il ya plus de cent ans au tri
parmi ces promus figurent cinq maréchaux
et plus de 600 généraux yuv 106 diplômé
de l'école ont obtenu les hautes
distinctions héros de l'union soviétique
un faux numéro de travail socialiste
était rosi de la fédération de russie
autre odeur c'est beaucoup de nos jours
à l'école cet établissement d'ellipses
qui forment des officiers montcuq pour
les unités des forces terrestres
heureuse
voici ce qui fait déraper
[Musique]
quant aux seconds gauche de cros
maintenant les musiciens alès le passage
aux troupes mécanisées la musique
militaire de la garnison de moscou luxe
vous remuer ce la baguette pour dieu
général-major artistes émérites et de la
russie
chute où le bruit des moteurs annonce le
début du défilé mécanisée sur la place
rouge
il comprend du matériel de l'époque de
la seconde guerre mondiale et des
armements modernes
brunner par 190 véhicules avons passé
sur les pavés de la place rouge
rabat
voilà l'honneur d'ouvrir le défilé
mécanisée et confiée aux militaires de
la première armée de chars de la garde d
ordre général sergueï qui servent ils
sont à bord de chars t 34 85 meilleure
charge de la seconde guerre mondiale
durant la guerre la première armée de
chars s'est illustré dans les combats et
apporter sa contribution à la défaite de
les nouveaux
la formation de servitude t34 qui est
emmenée par le capitaine et sergei ces
gros mots
[Musique]
ce minimum est il des filets des
armements modernes en dotation dans les
forces armées de la fédération us y est
ouvert par le passage des véhicules
appartenant à la 45e brigades spéciales
de la garde du capitaine il va sont des
véhicules blindés multi rôles et iphone
vdv équipés de modules de télécommande
youcam appuyé par celui détachement du
15e régiment de la garde d'infanterie
mécanisée shining civile faisant partie
de la division de taman sous les ordres
du commandant dimitri ces hommes sont à
bord de véhicules de combat d'infanterie
bnp deux équipés d'un module de kouba
verchocq des véhicules lourds de combat
d'infanterie de nouvelle génération
cours gagnait 2,25 équipé d'un module de
combat et pourquoi
[Musique]
formation de la 27e brigade de la garde
d'enfants tri mécanisé de sébastopol est
composé de véhicules de combat
d'infanterie bmp 3 elle est placée sous
les ordres du commandant igor matveïev
ces véhicules assure le transport et
l'appui feu des troupes mécanisées
durant le combat en toutes circonstances
[Musique]
grâce mes proches et place rouge
accueille une colonne de chars de combat
t-72 b 3ème but appartenant au 1er
régiment de la garde de charger
caustique qui porte le nom du maréchal
qatofin divisible régiment fait partie
de la division de tamani la formation
est conduite par le capitaine racing
taguiyev ce régiment est décoré de six
ordres militaires récompensant les faits
de guerre de ses soldats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du chaos
viennent ensuite les chars de combat t80
pvm équipé de turbomoteurs ses chars
sont en dotation à la 200e brigade
d'infanterie mécanisée
la formation est sous les ordres du
capitaine alexandre corniche cette
brigade protège les frontières de la
russie dans la zone arctique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici veut dire une formation de
matériel blindé de type 2 les plus
récents en dotation de la 27e brigade de
la garde d'infanterie mécanisée de
sébastopol sous les ordres du chef de
bataillon constantin au sol cette suisse
ce sont des chars de rabat et 80 m au
rif et et 14
[Musique]
la place rouge accueille des armements
des troupes de missiles et d'artillerie
des forces armées de la fédération de
russie
[Musique]
alexis
une division de ce fait les premiers
défilés sont les missiles balistiques de
courte et moyenne portée à haute
précision de tir iskander m d'autant la
112e brigade de la garde de l'étendard
de la brigade anti brigade porte cet
ordre militaire y compris l'ordre
alexandre nevsky ses décorations
récompense la bravoure de ses soldats
lors de la libération de nos grossistes
et franchissions du nieppe de loder et
de la prise de berlin
[Musique]
grâce aux divisions viennent ensuite
mais lance roquettes multiples
moderniser tornados dotation à la cape
139e brigade de la garde les actifs de
père écope
la formation est conduite par le
capitaine du véniat minh triet qui les
militaires de la brigade perpétuent les
traditions des légendaires katusha
[Musique]
l'artillerie des forces terrestres est
représenté par une colonne d'oublier
automoteurs de 152 mm écho à leeds as v
et qui pense la 236e brigade
d'artillerie qui défilent sous les
ordres du commandant italie victor hawks
qu'au système moderne de produits de le
tir et les performances techniques
poussées offert à ses systèmes
d'artillerie une haute précision et une
grande puissance de tir
[Musique]
chez kruger la place rouge accueille fut
des unités de défense aérienne des
forces terrestres
[Musique]
mayer servier
le détachement est commandée par le
commandant en second
cette unité présente des systèmes
d'armes solaire d'or m2 appartenant au
régiment de la garde de tarnopol faisant
partie de la quatrième division contenir
austère des systèmes d'armes sol air ou
même trois appartenant à la 53e brigade
anti aériennes de berlin
ces armes modernes sont capables de
faire face aux frappes aériennes de
nature différente
viennent ensuite des systèmes d'armes
solaire et force à éros faciale les
premiers à défiler sont les systèmes
antiaériens missiles canon 26s du 600
12e régiment de la garde de kiev sous
les angles commandant oceguera chichkine
[Musique]
l'unité a été récompensé par cinq
décorations militaires pour des faits de
bière
[Applaudissements]
chez ducati venir les systèmes d'armes
en sait rien et anti missiles s-400
triumph nous dotant le 93e régiment de
la garde qui sous les ordres du
commandant de l'auteur ou andre johnson
grâce à ses performances le système
d'armes s 400 entrées dispose d'une
avance qu'elle file du petit qualitative
évidente sur les autres systèmes aériens
de même catégorie
il est capable de détruire tous les
moyens existants d'attaqués aériennes et
les missiles balistiques
[Musique]
devant les tribunes passe différents
matériels des troupes aéroportées
ce sont des véhicules de combat blindés
md 4ème une nouvelle génération équipant
la 106e division aéroportée de la garde
bazerque ou là des files sous les ordres
du commandant dennis ces véhicules sont
inégalés au niveau de leur vitesse de
déplacement de la puissance de feu et
des altitudes de parachutage mans
[Musique]
l'odeur
ma mini motos tricycles
viennent ensuite les véhicules blindés
multi rôles moderniser bta mdm bush
comme appartenant au 137e régiment
aéroporté de la garde
basée à rien
[Musique]
ils sont conduits par le capitaine il
douce altenberg
[Musique]
on est toujours voici venir une
formation de lance roquettes multiples
moderniser tôt ce tir des projectiles
clairement barré
[Musique]
ils équipent la première brigade mobile
des troupes de protection nbc
ces véhicules des films sous les ordres
du capitaine de mitry de métro
[Musique]
le chien petit crâne n'est possible sur
les pavés de la place rouge s'avance une
colonne de véhicules de pause le minent
le transport et de rechargement qui font
partie de briques du système de minage à
distance et sdm
ils sont en dotation à la première
brigade le gêner brest berlin les
véhicules défilent sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel de maîtrise
l'oubli 10 nov ce système deux ménages à
distance est doté d'un équipement de
pointe qui permet de poser les champs de
mines les plus complexes
[Musique]
la place rouge accueille les drones
terrestre d'appui feu du courant 19 sous
les ordres du commandant alexeï
kukushkin alexis ces véhicules ne fait
preuve de leur efficacité lors des
opérations en république arabe syrienne
leur armement permet d'accomplir sur le
champ de bataille
toutes les missions proposées mythe et
intérêts
[Musique]
la police militaire des forces armées de
la fédération de russie vous présente
les véhicules blindés haute protection
des grandes capacités de franchissement
patrouille et iphone ils défilent sous
les ordres du commandant pavel maxime
brillault maxime moniot comme habile et
ces véhicules sont utilisés par la
police militaire dans les opérations de
combat et pour accueillir un supérieur
qui des missions spéciales
devant les tribunes défilent les
véhicules de la garde nationale de la
fédération de russie sous les ordres du
commandant alexeï
[Musique]
ce sont des véhicules blindés petits
grains patrouille et orale destiné à la
conduite des opérations dans des
conditions difficiles
m
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine
visible la place rouge accueille une
colonne mécanisée de troupes de missiles
stratégiques
elle est composée de robes mobile de
lancement de missiles balistiques
intercontinentaux yark pour de temps et
à la 54e des visions de la gare
valade même région ils sont sous les
ordres du lieutenant colonel dramane le
système balistique yar est capable de
franchir toute défense antimissile
existantes
les unités doter de missiles le système
d'armes yaars sont le fleuron du
groupement mobile d force
[Musique]
voilà
nicchi
le défilé mécanisée s'achèvent par des
véhicules blindés de combat d'infanterie
à roubaix qui présente les étendards de
toutes les armées des forces armées
russes
tu m as bien sommet
c'est le début du défilé aérien
[Musique]
le défilé aérien ouvert par trois
hélicoptères lourds
willi 26 le groupe est guidé par le
commandant igor checa y avait un groupe
de cinq hélicoptères multi rôles 1008ha
mt chat le groupe est sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel nicolas sarkoy m
viennent ensuite des hélicoptères
d'attaqué mille et mille 35ème émis 24
la formation est amené par le
lieutenant-colonel guennadi goliat
cauvin vous voyez maintenant cinq
hélicoptères d'attaqué de reconnaissance
kamov ka 52 alligator la patrouille est
sous les ordres du colonel basilique les
secours
la place rouge est survolée par la
patrouille acrobatique berkut avec le
royal et ses hélicoptères mil mi 28n
chasseur de nuit
la patrouille équité par le lieutenant
colonel edouard cause à chuck dans le
ciel de moscou une formation de trois
avions de transport iliouchine il 76 mde
sous les ordres du commandant mikhail
krasnov un yacht show qui lé commandant
andré yves beck aube et ivan d'or faye m
une démonstration de ravitaillement en
vol du bon partir stratégique du palais
vers 95 par l'avion de ravitaillement
illégaux chine 78 tout ravitaillement
vols de bombardiers stratégiques
supersonique et tu polaire 160 lui
permet d'accomplir des missions dans des
régions les plus éloignées du club
les avions sont pilotés par le
lieutenant-colonel roslan khamitov et le
commandant mikhail me chine
vient ensuite un autre bon papier
stratégique supersonique qui paul eve
160 piloté par le commandant à bord
petrenko
il est escorté par quatre chasseurs
d'aviation tactique
[Musique]
suivent les voici une patrouille de
quatre chasseurs multirôle de génération
4 + + chocolate 35s sous les centres du
lieutenant-colonel alex et jusqu'à
repeints
[Musique]
le défilé aérien continue avec le
passage de bombardiers tactiques
moderniser et jusqu'au 24
m
sous les ordres du lieutenant colonel
germann annacone
[Musique]
big foot toujours plus privé la patrie
suivante est composé de sa soeur laure
mig-35 à une armée de missiles
hypersonique qu'ils allaient la
patrouille est amené par le commandant
alexeï malachenko
[Musique]
et voici une formation de chasseur de
cinquième génération se recueille 57
sous les ordres du lieutenant colonel
vladimir voltchkov
dans le ciel de moscou une formation
tactique et qui comprend six appareils
de combat ce sont des bombardiers sucre
et 34 des chasseurs chico et 30 sms
choco et 35 sous les ordres du colonel y
auriez grippe sailhenc off
[Musique]
ou des clubs au dessus de la place rouge
le fameux diamant de copines cas cette
formation est composée de chasseurs su
cohérente smc mig 29 qui équipe les deux
célèbres patrouilles acrobatiques les
roues ce qui évite quasi prusse et
l'estrie j martin et la patrouille est
sous le commandement du colonel andré
alexeyev le défilé aérien se termine par
le passage sous le commandement du
lieutenant colonel de la dmr mandat sauf
de six avions d'attaqué au sol sur cauet
25 points mls dans le ciel ce un panache
des trois couleurs du drapeau russe
au relais
cette patrouille et est conduite par un
lieutenant-colonel la demir mort d'hasan
on ne va pas
le défilé s'achève par le sang la
victoire est toujours jeune interprété
par la musique militaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
ouais
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
ouais j'suis à nu
qui
youtube la musique militaire au shit la
place rouge solaire un dieu de la femme
slab le défilé militaire prend son terme
en chine
célébrons le 76e anniversaire de la
grande victoire aura loire aux anciens
combattants de la grande guerre
patriotique pour un bonne fête à tous
les citoyens de la russie pourra
[Musique]
allez ce défilé à 2 76e anniversaire de
la victoire sur l'allemagne nazie qu'on
vient de vivre ensemble sur rt france
voilà la place rouge se vident le
président de la dîmière poutine que vous
voyez actuellement à l'écran à quitte la
tribune officielle on a vu énormément de
choses pendant plus d'une heure alors de
ce fait défiler tout d'abord les
militaires à pied étaient excessivement
nombreux sur cette place rouge plus en
plus il ensuite les véhicules motorisés
et enfin à les avions ainsi que les
hélicoptères un défilé et qui aura duré
dans son ensemble at au chrtr dit une
heure et 12 minutes très exactement on
va bien sûr à 1 commenté à tout ça lors
de notre édition spéciale qui devrait
commencer dans quelques instants le
président vladimir poutine vos loyers a
toujours sur la place rouge du côté de
moscou et qui devrait ne pas tardé à
déposer une gerbe de fleurs moment
traditionnel pour le président vladimir
poutine vous le voyez sur ces images on
le voit entouré de deux militaires je
vous laisse quelques instants avec ces
images le dépôt de la gerbe de fleurs
ses dents et quelques instants et on
revient tout de suite après pour
commenter ensemble cette fois son 16e
cérémonie de la victoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au pôle
[Musique]
m
carte de france il est 10h15 à paris à
11h15 à moscou si vous nous rejoignez on
vient de vivre ensemble et on dire avec
cette immense défilé militaire en
l'honneur du 66e anniversaire de la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie édition
spéciale sur rt francs jusqu'à 11h30 on
débrief cette journée avec nos envoyés
spéciaux à moscou ainsi que noël invité
je vous le disais dispositif donc
exceptionnelle aujourd'hui pour vivre
ensemble est cette journée du 9 mère
défilé qui a eu lieu cette année
contrairement à l'année dernière pour
des raisons sanitaires et suite à
l'épidémie de kobe 19 une parade bien
sûr en présence du président vladimir
poutine le président russe a tenu à
rendre hommage aux vétérans et à tous
ceux qui ont connu la seconde guerre
mondiale pour revenir justement sur ce
défilé on ira voir tout au long de cette
matinée nos reporters sur place à moscou
et que l'on retrouvera à dents et
quelques minutes et on va prendre la
direction justement de paris pour
retrouver un autre invité
maurice leroy moscou au pardon on va
prendre la direction tout de suite de
moscou pour retrouver notre premier
invité de la matinée maurice leroy
ancien ministre de la ville de nicolas
sarkozy et ex député udi et du loir et
cher il est actuellement membre du
conseil d'administration de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie franco russe
maurice leroy bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes bien à moscou apa à paris
comme comme je le disais vous avez vécu
avec nous un 76e anniversaire de la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie tout
d'abord qu'est-ce que vous retenez de ce
défilé militaire et de ses débuts de
cérémonie bonjour tout à fait c'est très
émouvant de voir non seulement ce défilé
cette très belle parade militaire mais
surtout les vétérans moi je suis très
touchée par l'image des vétérans qui ont
vécu cette guerre et qui sont encore
présents
j'étais il ya peu de temps à volgograd
donc pour commémorer les morts de la
terrible et douloureuse bataille de
stalingrad et là il y avait un vétéran
qui avait participé à ces batailles de
staline c'était très très émouvant très
impressionnant nous y étions avec
plusieurs chefs d'entreprises français
gilles rémy qui était sur votre antenne
je crois ce matin le président de la
chambre de commerce d'industrie êtes
bien voulu citer emmanuel quidet et
participent à ces cérémonies et
représente les entreprises françaises
donc il faut rappeler pour vos auditeurs
que et le président qui dès le vie très
régulièrement que la france pour le
savoir les entreprises françaises sont
le premier employeur étranger en russie
donc c'est très important pour nous
français qui vivons qui travaillons en
russie d'être à côté de nos amis russes
pour commémorer ce souvenir
faut vraiment mesuré que ya pas une
famille où il n'y a pas eu de mort où on
n'a pas été touché par ce second conflit
mondial donc c'est très important je le
dis pour nos amis français parce que
hier c'était le 8 mai chez nous mais ici
c'est une vraie tradition les gens
s'écrivent se félicite se congratulent
envoient des messages très chaleureux
j'en ai reçu moi même dans les familles
donc c'est vraiment vécu il faut
ressentir ça j'essaie de vous faire
partager ça c'est pas seulement une
commémoration militaire c'est un vrai
une vraie cérémonie du souvenir et de la
mémoire qui imprègne toutes les familles
y compris les jeunes compris la jeunesse
ce qui me marque aussi celle les jeunes
sont impliqués sont touchés par cette
cérémonie
maurice leroy vous vous parliez à
l'instant toutes ces familles touchées
par la seconde guerre mondiale justement
en quoi à cette journée particulièrement
importante pour le peuple russe
elle est importante parce que les
familles se souviennent se réunissent se
rassemblent et suivent d'ailleurs à la
télévision beaucoup pour ce parce qu'à
cause de la pandémie comme vous savez
tout le monde ne peut pas être sur la
place rouge
par rapport à ce qui se passait il ya
deux ans notamment on vit ça aussi dans
les cérémonies du 8 mai j'ai regardé ce
qui se passait chez moi en loir-et-cher
et en vendômois la ville de vendôme dont
j'ai été longtemps le député ben j'ai vu
que voilà il y avait il n'y avait pas
non plus la population puisque du fait
de la pandémie on ne peut pas encore
avoir de manifestations publiques
et c'est aussi un peu le cas ici à
moscou mais du coup c'est vécu dans les
familles les gens se réunissent sont en
famille il ya habituellement ce set
extraordinaire défilé qu'on appelle des
immortels j ai participé il ya deux ans
et j'assure c'était très émouvant
impressionnant devant toutes ces
familles c'est populaire c'est simple et
jenson était dans la rue avec des
portraits ça ne peut pas avoir lieu
cette année ça n'a pas eu lieu l'année
dernière toujours à cause de la coved et
de la pandémie mais c'est très émouvant
donc c'est cette fête de la victoire
puisque c'est son nom
cette fête de la victoire elle est vécue
par les familles et par tout le peuple
russe donc c'est très très important et
c'est très émouvant de d'y participer
maurice laura vous restez avec nous bien
ur je vous le disais un dispositif
exceptionnel aujourd'hui pour vous faire
vivre comme si vous y étiez cette grande
journée de célébrations en l'honneur de
la victoire lors de la seconde guerre
mondiale à nos reporters monaco dès lors
en trunk l'hérault et à doha abdelrazik
sont sur place sont par justement les
retrouver
[Musique]
doha je me tourne vers vous on a vécu un
se défiler ensemble et en direct sur rt
france
une parade particulièrement apprécié
impressionnante c'est comme ça que vous
l'avez vécu aussi sur place alors moi je
vais être honnête avec vous je les avais
pu d'une manière assez exceptionnelle il
faut savoir que c'est peut-être l'un des
plus grandioses l'un des plus grands
moments ici en russie est peut-être
l'une des plus belles parades
un militaire au monde vous avez vu tous
ces soldats ces militaires qui ont
défilé plus de douze mille hommes
beaucoup de matériel également des
véhicules blindés des chars
et puis le cloud peut être de ce
spectacle ce magnifique un défilé aérien
qu'on a vu ici dans le ciel de moscou
alors je suis quand même une grande
chanceuse parce que je suis sur les
toits de moscou et j'avais l'impression
que juste en levant le bras elle est
peut-être à frapper un ses avions là
vous excuser j'ai beaucoup de mal à
articuler à cause du froid et du vent
moi j'ai vécu cette parade tout près du
ciel je vous propose d'aller voir
mona mood qui elle est bien avec eux
vraiment cette cérémonie au coeur de la
place rouge d'ailleurs c'est ici mais il
ya 76 ans précisément le 9 mai 45 que
les soldats soviétiques ont battu le
pavé
mona vous êtes avec nous comment vous
vous avez vécu justement cette cérémonie
en plein coeur de la place rouge alors
doré pire si vous avez trouvé que
c'était exceptionnel
imaginez moi je suis juste à quelques
mètres j'étais à quelques mètres de tous
ces chars de toutes ses troupes et c'est
extrêmement impressionnant et très aisée
vent puisque même les journalistes ici
ce regard d entre eux et certains
étaient très très ému et c'est d'autant
plus impressionnant on voir tous ces
véhicules militaires qui passe juste
derrière nous pour vous dire à leur
passage on sentait la terre trembler ce
look et si l'on veut dire à quel point
c'était impressionnant
alors on a vu plusieurs chars plusieurs
véhicules militaires passaient notamment
l'été 34 l'été huit les blindés légers
et les chars t-90 c'est un petit peu le
fer de lance de l'armée russe ou encore
le nous voir matt at&t 14 le plus
prestigieux
on a également pu voir des missiles
balistiques d'environ 30 mètres de long
et ça ça aussi c'est extrêmement
impressionnant à voir surtout si c'est à
quelques mètres de nous en tout cas
c'était une cérémonie extrêmement
émouvante et en même temps
impressionnante
[Musique]
alors bien évidemment il faut savoir que
pendant la guerre à la grande guerre
patriotique vient il y avait des soldats
qui étaient au front il ya eu également
les femmes les femmes ont joué un rôle
très important dans cette grande guerre
patriotique on le rappelle c'est une
guerre qui a commencé le 21 22 juin 1941
elle s'est terminée le 9 mai 1945 c'est
à cette époque que l'union soviétique
s'est engagé auprès des alliés pour
justement renverser le l'allemagne et
l'asie les nazis d'ailleurs ont capitulé
alors mona l'importance aussi de la
femme était représentée ici puisque il y
a également voilà des troupes féminines
qui ont défilé aujourd'hui sur la place
rouge où il exactement de randonnée
plusieurs unités plusieurs troupes de
femmes dénudées filer à quelques mètres
ici il faut savoir que dans l'armée
russe il ya un peu plus de 40000 de
femmes des femmes militaires qui ont des
rôles importants dans plusieurs unités
notamment dans l'armée de l'air puisque
de plus en plus de femmes sont formés
pour devenir pilote s'était éteint
défiler un militaire terrestre certes
mais qui s'est terminée en musique alors
lors de cette cérémonie il y a deux
chants traditionnels que beaucoup d'eau
russes connaissent le premier c'est la
guerre sacrée c'est un champ de la
seconde guerre mondiale et puis il ya le
second qui s'appelle l'adieu à cela va
c'est l'histoire d'un soldat qui part au
front et qui quitte sa bien aimée donc
on a vraiment une heure de cette
cérémonie beaucoup
une démonstration de force et de
puissance de la part de l'armée russe
mais également beaucoup d'émotion
puisque c'était une fête qui est
extrêmement important d qui représente
beaucoup à car tous les russes ont été
touchés dans leur chair ont perdu un
membre important de leur famille lors de
cette guerre et pour finir eh bien ce
risque
le gâteau j'ai envie de vous dire il a
suffit de lever les yeux pour voir ce
défilé aérien avec tous ses avions
c'est bombardier ou encore ces abandons
chaise qui était à basse altitude
environ 180 mètres c'était extrêmement
impressionnant de quoi nous faire
décoller
[Musique]
effectivement à décoller je vous le
disais il faisait suffisait peut-être de
lever le bras pour attraper les avions
dans le ciel qui ont à la fin donc avec
ces fumigènes a montré le beau drapeau
de la russie dans le ciel alors mouna
merci vous avez parlé de l'émotion des
journalistes l'émotion aussi de tout le
peuple russe
pas seulement le peuple russe puisque il
faut savoir que le neuf mais aussi et c
est vrai dans les anciens pays de
l'union soviétique
l'urss qui a payé un lourd tribut
pendant cette guerre 27 millions de
victimes des soldats beaucoup de civils
et comment on l'a dit votre invité
d'ailleurs la dir pierre il ya quelques
minutes
c'est une guerre très importante pour
les russes car il n'y a pas une seule
famille ici qui n'a pas perdu un de ses
membres
justement on va tâter le pouls des des
russes même qui sont dans la rue car
j'en vois quelques un duo justement du
toit de moscou il ya certaines personnes
qui se sont mis dans la rue pour pouvoir
apercevoir peut-être certains chars et
puis apprécier donc c'est cette parade
aérienne
antoine claireaux vous êtes là avec nous
vous êtes justement dans les rues de la
capitale russe vous êtes allés à la
rencontre de ces gens comment quelle est
l'atmosphère qu'elle est l'émotion que
leur sens aujourd'hui
dis moi vite s'il faut que je
antoine
oui tout à fait alors comme vous pouvez
voir derrière moi ici le défilé continue
car je me trouve sur la route du retour
tous ces engins militaires qui sont
passés sur la place rouge il ya quelques
minutes
et bien maintenant deal il remonte via
l'avenue qui se trouve derrière moi il
remonte vers le nord de la capitale
russe de là où ils sont partis dans la
matinée alors pour beaucoup de russes il
s'agit d'un véritable rituel que de
suivre ce défilé de la victoire du 9 mai
que ce soit à la télévision pour
beaucoup ou bien pour les plus courageux
comme aujourd'hui avec cette météo
capricieuse et bien directement dans la
rue au plus près de ces engins de c'est
d'ailleurs très impressionnant pour pour
les plus jeunes pour les enfants qui
dont se sont donc impressionné parfois
effrayés par la taille et par le bruit
de ces engins et pour les plus âgés
c'est davantage le souvenir le
recueillement pour tous ses proches qui
ont disparu ou qui ont participé à
l'effort de guerre contre le nazisme
d'autant plus que cette année pour la
deuxième année consécutive il n'y a pas
de défilé du régiment immortel vous
savez cette marche hockey à laquelle
participent des centaines de milliers de
russes chaque année en temps normal avec
à la main le portrait le portrait d'un
proche un parent un grands parents
arrière grands parents qui a disparu
pendant cette grande guerre patriotique
vous savez maintenant c'est le nom donné
ici à la seconde guerre mondiale donc
ici beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion une
émotion à ces primaires pour les plus
jeunes et du recueillement le souvenir
pour les plus âgés mais toujours dans
une atmosphère de fête
[Musique]
voilà une atmosphère de fête en tout cas
merci beaucoup antoine de nous avoir
fait voilà fait vivre et ressentir cette
émotion justement dans les rues de la
capitale
voilà russe alors la journée n'est pas
terminée bien évidemment il ya encore
d'autres festivités gens vous en
parlerai un petit peu plus tard et on va
retrouver aussi nos invités en tout à
l'heure qui vont également voilà nous
racontait un petit peu plus en détail
leurs impressions également vers un
petit peu un petit point historique sur
ce fameux jour de la victoire
donc voilà un magnifique défilé un que
vous avez pu regarder en direct en tout
cas sur rt france je vous laisse pierre
avec votre invité est oui doha on ne
manquera pas de vous retrouver dans
quelques minutes un vous qui êtes sur
les sur les toits de moscou avec cette
magnifique vue merci également à antoine
frérot et amon à amou dès lors pour
leurs impressions sur place et pendant
que vous nous donniez justement vos
impressions on a vu le président
vladimir poutine être posée justement
une gerbe de fleurs devant la flamme du
soldat inconnu c'était au pied du
kremlin voilà moment de recueillement à
traditionnels pour le président russe
vladimir poutine
voilà on revient avec nos invités ici
maurice leroy vous étiez avec nous tout
à l'heure vous êtes encore là je le
rappelle vous êtes conseil d'admin 7
membres du conseil d'administration de
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
franco russe vous avez suivi cette
journée cette matinée avec nous à nos
reporters sur le terrain parler tout de
suite de l'émotion un forcément susciter
chez les russes
quels sont les stigmates que la seconde
guerre mondiale a laissé en russie
d'abord je pense que la force du symbole
et c'est une occasion de se rassembler
de dépasser les différences c'est cela
aussi que montre cette belle parade avec
ce défilé très populaire en réalité donc
voilà je pense qu'en fait on
comment vous dire moi j'ai un petit
regret c'est que on devrait aujourd'hui
avoir une communion internationale
autour de cette belle fête de la
victoire sur le nazisme sur la barbarie
nazie le racisme et ça ça devrait
rassembler internationalement
je regrette que les tensions et là ce
qui existe ne permettent pas ça plus la
pandémie villa est une réalité objectif
donc vous parler des stigmates ses
stigmates
il existe encore une fois vos reporter
donc très bien dit je les dis moi même
il faut le répéter le marteler sans
cesse tant de morts encore une fois je
reviens sur la label cérémonie que nous
avons eue grâce à pierre malinowski son
organisation parfaite
il ya eu d'ailleurs un très beau
reportage sur france 2 hier soir merci à
france 2 d'avoir fait ce magnifique
reportage très émouvant vous vous rendez
compte dans l'une des tons dans les
fouilles qui ont été faites par pierre
malinowski et puis de les français qui
ont participé à ces fouilles des
étudiants notamment
eh bien on retrouvait le corps d'un
homme d'un adolescent de 16 ans qui
était enterrée avec d'autres soldats
russes
encore une fois pas une famille qui
n'ait été touchés donc c'est c'est très
fort
c'est plus qu'un défilé ou une parade
militaire c'est un une vraie force
populaire un vrai sentiment populaire et
là aussi je le redis dans les familles
c'est vibrant de toutes les générations
toutes les générations sont concernés
regardez dans vos images on voyait
beaucoup de jeunes dans les rues venir
voir le défilé
ils sont avec le papa la maman le
grand-père la grand mère voilà c'est un
vrai rassemblement et c'est dommage que
la pandémie en pêche et on peut le
comprendre pour des raisons de sécurité
sanitaire bien compréhensible c'est bien
dommage que on puisse pas vivre mais
vivement qu'on puisse le faire de
nouveau ce ce défilé populaire saint leu
familiale qui s'appelle les immortels
c'est un nom magnifique d'avoir donné le
nom des immortels et les gens viennent
avec un portrait dans la famille des
leurs qui sont morts qui ont été blessés
ou qui sont morts dans ce terrible
second conflit mondial donc c'est très
très émouvant et notamment rdcb téhéran
qui entouraient le président vladimir
poutine voilà c'est très émouvant de
devoir cela moi j'ai pu y participer il
ya deux ans j'étais il ya deux ans sur
la place rouge sûr que c'est très fort
comme sentiment voilà beaucoup d'émotion
c'est en tout cas ce que vous nous dites
merci beaucoup à maurice leroy d'avoir
été avec nous pour cette journée
spéciale je répète je rappelle que vous
êtes son ancien ministre de la ville et
ex-député u10 du loir-et-cher est
actuellement membre du conseil
d'administration de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie franco russe
merci à vous pour votre présence
avec nous aujourd'hui on continue bien
sûr de parler de cette journée spéciale
76e anniversaire de la victoire des
alliés sur l'allemagne nazie nous sommes
maintenant avec françois costantini
géopolitologue bonjour françois
costantini merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce matin on vient de le voir les
célébrations du 9 mai en russie sont
plus importantes que celles du 8 mai en
france
comment on peut expliquer un tel
décalage bonjour merci de votre team
owner tout particulièrement
je pense que yi il ya un contraste en
effet entre cette cette parade
magnifique seconde commémoration qui est
exceptionnel au monde
et puis les cérémonies rabri recchi qui
je pense qu'ils ne font pas vraiment
honneur en france à aux sacrifices
qu'ils se sont dit il il ya soixante il
ya 76 ans première chose moi je pense
que je me souviens un peu ans bien 74
j'étais encore écoliers et ma famille
avait été choqué parce que valéry
giscard d'estaing nouvellement élu avait
déclaré qu'on a c'est la bresle plus
miné le menu mais je cite où c'est le
travail de façon au moindre set et pull
férié pour me disent et ils pourront pas
d'épée pas d'écart à l'allemagne avec la
can comme l'a engagé dans la
construction européenne tout est dit je
pense qu'aujourd'hui pour pas déplaire à
l'allemagne on n'en fait pas trop
lui-même alors que c'est une grande
victoire
on sait si une fois rld et ali
c'est une victoire bien sûr des peuples
de l'union de son mythique du peuple
russe en en particulier et je pense que
comme la dimension tout à l'heure ça
aurait dû être un moment de communion
internationale entre tous les ans les
anciens alliés les peuples ont ce petit
peuple russe français britannique
américain mais je pense que aujourd'hui
on est plus soucieux en effet d'écarter
la russie de ces cérémonies est de faire
plaisir en quelque sorte de ne pas
froisser en quelque sorte l'albane et je
pense que c'est assez choquant françois
constantini a en quoi le souvenir de
millions de soldats tombés sur le champ
de bataille continue même 76 ans après
est cimentée justement la nation russe
c'est un sacrifice nous sans bien sûr
retirer le mérite l'engagement des
battants alliés américains britanniques
australiens de la résistance française
faut pas oublier il faut quand même pas
oublier que sur les 5 millions et demi
de soldats ou que l'allemagne nazie a
perdu elle en a elles ces quatre
millions sur le champ de bataille
soviétiques et que les peuples de
l'union soviétique le peuple russe
particulièrement ont dû à déplorer 20
millions de morts donc je pense que la
victoire et c'est à l'ancien c'est un
anti communiste anti soviétique qui nous
parle
la victoire en effet contre l'allemagne
nazie c'est l'union soviétique ce sont
les peuples d'union soviétique qui ont
eu le plus grand le plus grand sacrifice
qu'ils ont commis qui se sont le plus
engagées
je vois que la victoire possible a été
rendue possible parce que par le rouleau
compresseur de l'armée rouge et ça il
faut pas l'oublier et je pense que je
suis heureux de voir ne prend tout cas
le le peuple russe garder en tout cas
une certaine fierté
on voudrait que de l'autre côté de
l'europe ce soit un petit peu pareil de
temps en temps et garder ce ciment
quelque sorte de l'histoire et et
montrer que la nation russe et est fier
d'elle et quelque part c'est rassurant
quelque sorte doit toujours nous de
russie qui porteront ses couleurs et
françois constantini vous allez à rester
a bien entendu
avec nous on va continuer avec vous
forcément de de décrypter d'analyser
tout ce qui s'est passé pendant son 76e
anniversaire de la victoire
on va prendre tout de suite la direction
de moscou rejoindre justement notre
reporter antoine gayraud antoine vous
êtes toujours dans les rues de moscou
racontez nous un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui comment vous avez vécu
vous sur place
cette cérémonie cette grande parade
militaire et bien en fait sur la majeure
partie du de cette parade militaire
le public ne pouvait pas ne pouvaient
pas accéder à tous à toutes et à tous
les défilés qui se trouvait avant la
place rouge mais par contre tout le
retour tout le chemin du retour des
engins militaires qui remontait vers le
nord de la capitale est bien là la foule
s'est retrouvée le défilé vient tout
juste de se terminer maintenant c'est
les véhicules municipaux qui ont nettoyé
la chaussée et on peut voir derrière moi
des premières voitures d'officiels qui
se trouvait dans les tribunes sur la
place rouge quitté la place rouge est
emprunter cette avenue pour rejoindre
leur ambassade ou ou leur bureau
donc voilà ce qu'on peut dire à l'heure
actuelle la foule commence à se dissiper
étant donné que cela fait maintenant
quelques minutes que plus aucun engin
militaire n'est pas c'est donc une foule
encore une fois je le disais très
impressionné par par cette parade en
particulier les plus jeunes parfois même
effrayés par le bruit par la taille des
engins et puis cette année n'ayant pas
n'ayant pas le défilé du régiment
immortel et bien beaucoup de gens sont
venus malgré tout avec on en a vu
quelques-uns avec une photo de leurs
proches nos parents un grand parent
disparu pendant cette grande guerre
patriotique que l'on célèbre aujourd'hui
le souvenir de ces gens là également
merci antoine gayraud on reviendra bien
sûr vers vous un tout au long de cette
matinée pour commenter avec vous
ce qui se passe actuellement à moscou on
a bien sûr beaucoup parlé pendant cette
émission à des militaires des engins des
avions il faut aussi parler de la
population la population moscovite qui a
parfois subi c'est cette guerre
subissent ces bombardements et payer le
prix lourd de la guerre beaucoup d'entre
eux se sont parfois est réfugié dans le
métro dans le métro de moscou vous le
savez une oeuvre d'art architecturale
qui a sauvé de nombreuses vies pendant
cette seconde guerre mondiale en effet
un je le disais lors des raids aériens
les moscovites se réfugier dans les
couloirs et dans les rames pour se
protéger voyez justement le reportage
dans le métro de moscou de notre
correspondant de radio fna les
souterrains le métro de moscou né dans
le monde entier pour sa beauté sans
parler de sa fiabilité et sa vitesse
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale sept
nervis artistique à sauver des vies
le 22 juillet 1941 en mois après le
début de la guerre moscou faisait face à
sa première attaque aérienne pendant les
bombardements jusqu'à un demi millions
de moscovites ont trouvé refuge dans le
métro aleph tino baranova âgé de 9 ans à
l'époque était avec sa soeur et sa mère
parmi ceux qui descendait sous terre
presque chaque soir quatre pôles comme
tina google quand il y avait une alerte
aérienne on nous faisait descendre dans
le métro
et donc nous descendions dans le métro
il y avait une rame à quai
seules les femmes enceintes et celles
avec des bébés y étaient admises ou les
personnes âgées très faible il n'est ni
guinée ils étaient tous les autres on
les faisait descendre par un escalier en
bois devant la première voiture dans le
tunnel pendant tout le bombardement on
restait dans le tunnel il n'y avait
nulle part où s'asseoir d'estonie les
dernières
lors d'une nuit de bombardement
particulièrement intensifs
il y avait trop de monde dans les
tunnels et alex steen a failli
suffoquait un vieil homme a dit mr
soulevé vos enfants au dessus de vos
têtes et faites-les passait sur le quai
pour qu'il ne crève pas ici c'est ce
qu'il a dit parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'air vous pouvez imaginer ça nous
étions petit et nous les petits on nous
a soulevé fait passer pour nous remettre
sur le pied
staub nos plates pour moi bonnet c est
une fois le raid aérien terminé les
parents se sont levés et ont récupéré
leurs enfants c'est arrivé une seule
fois nous sommes restés debout pendant
tout le bombardement en attendant
l'annoncé fin de l' alerte fin de l'
alerte le raid aérien est terminée
pendant la guerre le métro servait de
transport et de refuge
mais on y trouvait aussi en hôpital une
bibliothèque et même un cinéma
pourquoi avons-nous un nombre
relativement bas de victimes et de morts
parce que dans les premiers mois de la
guerre beaucoup de travail a été
accomplie pour préparer des abris pour
la population le métro de moscou est
célèbre pour son ordre et sa propreté
les stations ont été nettoyés et
désinfectés tous les jours on se prépare
est vraiment pour faire tout ça
le métro cessé de fonctionner en tant qu
abri à 5 heures du matin mais certains
passagers restés pour aider le personnel
de la station et faire le ménage pendant
la guerre tout le pays a vécu un même
élan on le front et l'arrière formé en
tout tout le monde littéralement tout le
monde essayait de faire tout son
possible et encore plus pour la victoire
au front bien sûr c'était dur mais à
l'arrière les gens travailler et ne
quittait pas leur poste pendant 10 12
heures voire plus non pas parce que
quelqu'un les forcer à le faire mais
parce qu'il voulait vraiment faire plus
bursa
pourvu qu'il n'y ait plus de guerre
répète souvent les anciens combattants
pourvu que ces murs voix soul man les
passagers et pas de refusiez voilà sujet
a signé verhaeghe hoffman dans le métro
de moscou qui n'est pas seulement vous
l'avez vu une oeuvre architecturale qui
a également servi à sauver ceux de
nombreuses vies lors de cette seconde
guerre mondiale voilà pourquoi il est
aussi important pour les moscovites ou
continue bien sûr de parler de cet
anniversaire 76e anniversaire du jour de
la victoire victoire en 1945 des alliés
sur l'allemagne nazie nous sommes
toujours avec notre invité françois
costantini
merci d'être encore là avec nous vous
avez aussi suivi 1 comme nous elle cette
cérémonie et ce défilé militaire pendant
son discours
vladimir poutine a réaffirmé je cite que
le pays défendra ses intérêts est ce que
vous savez à quoi il fait allusion
je pense que de l'otan depuis que va
dire poutine accéder la présence de la
russie la russe qui est revenue je crois
que en toute simplicité dans le jeu
international
c'est à dire qu'on a vu la déliquescence
où j'ai assisté il maintient en russie
fin 91 j'étais d'ailleurs si je pars un
peu personnel au moment des 50 ans de la
défense de moscou 87 des gens sentent
révérence cette ferveur je pense que la
russie tout simplement et robin d'anjou
internationale elle fait valoir ses
intérêts sans agressivité mais elle
également s est relevé et je pense que
en effet aujourd'hui il ya une politique
qui à mon sens dangereuses à l'égard de
la russie
ces 700 tentative d'extension de l'otan
à l'est au leader de la russie qui ne
peut que accentuer la fracture à intra
européennes et là je te comprend en
effet que la russie pose un certain
nombre d'intérêts quant à sa sécurité
quand un défi alors qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons des menaces comme l'islamisme
radical mondial comme le terrorisme
comme les défis migratoires
est ce qu'on a besoin d'introduire une
fracture majeure au sein de l'europe et
d'avoir cette guerre froide larvé avec
la russie moi je réponds non
et je comprends en effet que la russie
défendre ses intérêts et je pense qu'il
faut converger
justement faire de la russie à
l'interlocuteur et non pas un adversaire
vous parler de fracture le président
vladimir poutine a également rappelé je
cite le retour dans le monde d'idéologie
à raciste et russophone est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous ressentez aussi
oui parce qu'on voit un peu partout dans
les discours surtout depuis le l'arrivée
d'administration by donne aux états unis
je cite et puis quand on regarde les
rapports et bien le rapport au temps
2030 dans lesquelles sont désignés comme
comme adversaire un la russie de deux la
chine les pays des occidentaux les états
unis les pays européens at il pas
d'autres adversaires aujourd'hui je
pense pas que ce soit la russie et la
chine qui en france et fait plus de 360
morts je parlais bien sûr des morts de
l'islamisme radical que nous avons des
pleurs en france et il n'y a pas
longtemps également une policière à son
comble et sous l'ailé sous les coups
d'un fanatiques islamistes et je pense
qu'en effet il s'agit d'une fausse route
qui risquent en effet de conduire vers
la bim verna un affrontement totalement
décalée avec les enjeux et je pense
qu'il faut cesser en effet deux des
conseils de conserver là que les états
unis considère la russie comme comme un
adversaire privilégié à l'ennemi
stratégie comme avait dit georges
d'abord du bush et qu'il faut revenir à
la raison au plan international merci
beaucoup françois causse continue
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin pour
commenter ensemble ce 76e anniversaire
jour de la victoire est justement ce
jour de la victoire on continue d'en
parler avec un nouvel invité jean de
gliniasty ancien ambassadeur de france
en russie et directeur de recherche à
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques hauteur de petite
histoire des relations franco russes ou
reddition de l'inventaire
bonjour jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
je les dis vous avez été ambassadeur de
france à moscou
gardez vous des souvenirs un particulier
du défilé du 9 mai auquel vous avez
assisté quand vous étiez à moscou
bonjour oui en effet j'ai assisté à cinq
du filet et à chaque fois c'est une
énorme fête
simplement j'ai noté il y a une espèce
de de baromètre de la situation
internationale dans ce dans ce défilé
quand il ya beaucoup d'invités étrangers
au plus haut niveau ça veut dire que les
relations sont bonnes quand il y en a
peu ça veut dire que les relations sont
mauvaises et on voit qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
période de tension vous le disiez un peu
de chefs d'état étrangers ont assisté à
ce défilé simplement des ambassadeurs
l'ambassadeur américain et
un membre de l'ambassade britannique
également justement les relations russe
avec les pays extérieurs on le sait
seront un peu compliqué en ce moment en
tout cas avec le monde occidental
c'est sûr que là l'accusé créé la crise
ukrainienne a été un facteur de tension
dans les relations entre la russie et le
monde occidental
on a vu récemment bien sûr d'aider des
expulsions d'ambassadeurs de part et
d'autre un de de la russie est ce que
cette tension diplomatique a pu avoir un
poids sur cette journée du 9 mai je
crois que c'est un ensemble
les expulsions de diplomates c'est un
peu comment dirais-je un signe mais
c'est un signe de deux de tension
globale et c'est sûr que ça a joué un
rôle bien entendu mais il ya beaucoup
d'éléments qui constitue en fait les les
facteurs de tensions actuellement on a
vu on va retenir va revenir bien entendu
sur cette cérémonie est ce ce défilé
militaire avec vous vous qui avez
assisté justement plusieurs fois à ce
défilé on a vu de nombreux vétérans
autour de 2 l'a dit mi-août in les
vétérans bien sûr ils sont excessivement
important pour pour cette cérémonie
oui alors la notion de vétérans a une
importance beaucoup plus grande en
russie que la notion d' anciens
combattants en france cela dit ne
serait-ce que démographiquement ses
vétérans de la deuxième guerre mondiale
la grande guerre patriotique sont en
train de disparaître petit à petit mais
la notion de vétérans reste un peu le
symbole de l'union 2
la nation russe face à l'envahisseur
nazi et même après leur disparition les
resteront un symbole très fort de
l'unité du pays
jour de klina si vous restez bien sûr
avec nous 10h51 sur rt france vous êtes
avec nous en direct pour vivre ensemble
ce jour de victoire du 9 mai un jour de
victoire est célébrée déjà au delà des
frontières de la russie et même plus
loin encore dans l'espace trois
astronautes de liesse ont envoyé un
message de félicitations habitants de la
terre je vous propose de les écouter
dans la gadoue zia si vos chers amis le
9 mai 2021 nous oleg nowitzki piotr
dubrovnik et marc van rijn pantin
saluons tous les habitants de la terre
depuis la station spatiale
internationale à l'occasion du grand
jour de la victoire à tokyo est bien
évident qu'il ya des bons ce jour même
il y à 76 ans la grande guerre
patriotique a pris fin cette journée est
à juste titre considéré comme l'un des
événements majeurs du xxème siècle qui a
déterminé le futur développement
pacifique de la civilisation humaine
nous nous souviendrons toujours des
grands exploits des soldats et des
travailleurs de guérir tes bras au bout
du lit
nous nous souviendrons des millions de
victimes avec l'aide desquels nos
grand-père et arrière-grand-père ont pu
arrêter les forces de destruction et
rétablir la paix le droit à la vie et la
liberté se souvenir sera pour nous
toujours sacré modération à ces
championnats mais c'est nous tous qui
vivons et travaillons à bord de la
station spatiale internationale sommes
unis dans un seul but poursuivre
pacifiquement les découvertes et les
recherches profit de l'humanité tout
entière est à venir c'est un brillant
exemple de coopération internationale a
donné ce soir et de la nasa c'est un
honneur pour nous de vivre dans ce
laboratoire de recherche international
mais alors rien
assez de nous félicitons la planète
terre de tout notre coeur en ce jour de
la victoire est bien des girondins nous
vous souhaitons à vous et à toute
l'humanité paix bonne santé bien être et
bonheur braga pas aux chiens nous sommes
de retour sur rt france toujours en
compagnie notre invité jean de gliniasty
le président poutine a rappelé tout à
l'heure son vif intérêt pour la défense
des intérêts nationaux de la russie
est ce que justement la guerre a permis
de solidifier ce sentiment patriotique
et comment oui cette guerre à vrai dire
le 9 mai c'est la vraie fête nationale
russe
le 12 juin peu de ruse savait exactement
ce que c'est donc que c'est un moment
d'unité puisque c'est le moment où
staline d'ailleurs a fait appel même au
soutien de la tradition orthodoxe pour
lutter contre l'envahisseur et donc
c'est un moment d'unité nationale
absolument exceptionnel pour la russie
qui transcende les différences
politiques
les questions de répression du temps de
staline est donc ce moment et ça crée
c'est vrai le mot n'est pas faible
vous parliez on parlait tout à l'heure
avec l'invité à précédent du discours de
vladimir poutine qui a dénoncé le retour
des idéologies xénophobes et russophobe
vous avez été ambassadeur de france en
russie est ce que la xénophobie la
russophobie y est ce que c'est des
choses que vous avez vécu à l'époque où
c'est quelque chose de nouveau jeu je
prendrais pas à mon compte le mot bus
aux phobiques est un qui est un élément
de gien de la tension actuelle de là la
discussion actuelle il est frappant de
voir que beaucoup de gens qui sont
extrêmement opposée à la russie actuelle
sont en même temps de le bon connaisseur
de la culture russe et de la langue
russe
donc il y à une utilisation
de beaucoup de thèmes dans antirusse
dans le dans le jeu des tensions
actuelles sommes en fait dans une
nouveau type de guerre froide alors on
peut qualifier ça de russophobie mais il
est clair que de part et d'autre tous
les instruments de puissance douce de
soft power sont utilisés au moment où
les tensions montent
je le disais tout à l'heure vous avez
été ambassadeur de france en russie
qu'elle ait les qualités l'état des
relations diplomatiques à l'époque entre
la france et la russie est ce qu'elle se
sont détériorés ou améliorés à l'époque
elle était excellent mais il y avait
déjà quelques petits éléments de tension
au moment de la crise libyenne puis
ensuite au moment de la cuisse de six
viennent évidemment ça s'est accentué et
l'ukraine la crise ukrainienne a été
évidemment le déclenchement de d'une
véritable père de tension cela dit je ne
dirais pas que les relations actuelles
soient à ce point dégradée que le
dialogue ait pris fin que des idées
intéressantes ne soit mise sur la table
il est clair que les idées de dû par
exemple du président la république
française sur une nouvelle architecture
de sécurité et de confiance en europe
reste valide donc ya des hauts et des
bas nous sommes dans une période de
tension incontestablement comme il y en
a eu eux depuis la la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
mais il ya sur la table un certain
nombre d'idées qui permettent de
redémarrer
j'ajouterai d'ailleurs que les
américains savent très bien qu'ils
doivent traiter avec la russie sur un
certain nombre de problèmes importants à
vous en avez parlé effectivement le
climat le terrorisme la question aussi
de l'évacuation de l'afghanistan
variable tout un toute une série de
questions qui doivent être traitées et
donc j'ai été très frappé par le fait
que la tension était à son comble en
ukraine il ya encore quelques semaines
et que c'est à la suite d'un entretien
entre
le président byden et le président
poutine que la tension a baissé donc de
toutes façons les éléments dialogues
sont là et il faut s'en réjouir
et personne ne conteste la nécessité de
se parler d'essayer de régler ensemble
des problèmes on le sait jean de
gliniasty les les relations entre la
france et la russie sont sont
historiques justement à comment vous
êtes senti en tant que français qu'on
vous étiez ambassadeur en russie est ce
que justement vous vous sentiez que les
russes avaient envie d'entretenir cdd
bonnes relations avec avec la france
incontestablement
incontestablement il y a comme je
l'expliqué dans mon lit mais il ya une
espèce d'affinités qui est dû à
l'histoire la culture qui est dû aussi à
quelques gammes héritage du général de
gaulle le régime en normandie niemen qui
reste très présent dans la mémoire des
russes
un petit peu moins des français parce
que les français ont souvent oublié leur
histoire mais il ya beaucoup d'éléments
qui font que un français se sent à
l'aise en russie incontestablement
merci beaucoup aux joueurs de gliniasty
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui sur
l'antenne d'arte france
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur de france en russie merci
d'avoir commenter avec nous ce 76e
anniversaire de du jour de la victoire
on continue bien entendu à part les 1 2
cette de cette journée 1 76e
anniversaire du jour de la victoire nous
sommes encore une fois avec gilles rémy
homme d'affaires qui a su tisser un lien
tout particulier avec la russie tout au
long de sa carrière
rebonjour gilles rémy merci d'être une
nouvelle fois avec nous sur rt france
pour évoquer est ce défilé ces
célébrations du 9 mai vous qui avez vécu
en russie qu'est ce que ça représente ce
9 mai pour les russes je crois que c'est
le flux et c'est là c'est la grande fête
nationale russe qui a ressoudé tout un
tout un peuple et tout un pays et même
qui était à l'époque soviétique qui
était en quelque sorte la pierre sur
laquelle reposait cette cette union et
je le disais tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui c'est le 9 mai est fêté dans
l'ensemble presque dans l'ensemble des
anciennes républiques socialistes
soviétiques
c'est un grand jour assez c'est l'un des
plus grands sacrifices qu une banque une
nation et plus et plus et plus de
données pour une guerre j'étais il ya
maurice leroy parler de stalingrad nous
y étions effectivement il ya deux
semaines c'était la deuxième fois que je
me rendais à chaque fois c'est une
émotion qui est intacte et on mesure on
mesure quand on est sur place ce
sacrifice humain mais aussi cette
organisation qui a permis de battre la
première la première armée du monde qui
était la norme les nazis on a vu un ces
célébrations du 9 mer énorme défilé
militaire on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
ce genre d'image en france comment
expliquer justement ce décalage entre
les célébrations en russie
en occident plusieurs facteurs il ya
d'une part historiquement que tout ce
que représente le 9 mai cette victoire
d'exceptionnel héroïque de la deuxième
guerre mondiale on l'a dit d'autres
interlocuteurs ont dit le poids
militaire le poids démographique de la
des sacrifices de la delà de la russie
mais il ya aussi je crois une volonté
aujourd'hui de montrer que la russie
après avoir été terriblement affaibli
dans les années 90 est une grande
puissance et que la russie
on a vu un défilé militaire qu on ne va
pas commenter la point de vue technique
mais imaginons aujourd'hui que la russie
a pratiquement la parité dans la plupart
des domaines peut être hors la marine
avec les etats-unis se détend avec des
états unis des contrats craint cette
fois plus d'argent à leur complexe
militaro-industriel que je rappelle
aussi qu'à ce fois en ce qui concerne le
budget de la russie en ce qui concerne
le talent et pourtant la russie est au
premier plan technologique moi je vous
assure que dans les années 90 quand on a
vu le délabrement l'effondrement de deux
lutins je n'aurais pas parié un kopeck
sur la capacité du complexe militaro
industriel de revenir un jour au premier
plan alors évidemment c'est dans une
période de crise internationale de la
relation de l'europe des états unis avec
la russie
parce que je pense qu'il s'agit bien de
l'occident la russie a d'excellentes
relations avec l'asie avec la chine mais
avec l'afrique avec amérique latine
donc dans cette période de confrontation
effectivement c'est un message la russie
est une est un grand pays sur lequel il
faut compter dans le monde et je crois
qu'il une fierté certainement très
naturelle de la part des ruches de voir
qu'il compte à nous aujourd'hui dans le
monde
je posais la question tout à l'heure à
jean de gliniasty
vous qui avez vécu en russie en quoi
votre avis la france a tout intérêt à
entretenir de bonnes relations avec la
russie
on adopte tout simplement parce que ça
correspond à nos intérêts nationaux
nous n'avons rien qui nous qui nous
amènerait à être en situation de
contentieux avec la russie la russie en
termes économiques ne nous pose aucun
préjudice
on n'assiste pas à des délocalisations
de notre industrie comme ça peut être le
cas avec la chine
donc ce n'est pas un concurrent
pratiquement économique au contraire
c'est un partenaire et puis il ya aussi
des actes d'intérêt commun a aujourd'hui
alors que notre industrie nucléaire a
menacé la russie est redevenu un des
pays majeurs et notre intérêt mutuel
effectivement c'est de faire en sorte
que le nucléaire ne sera pas effacé de
nos mixte énergétique
donc en fait objectivement il n'y a pas
de raison je vois qu ils raison c'est
certes un peu à ces cétacés est
d'ailleurs unis dans l'histoire et les
tiennent peut-être plus à un conflit qui
devient un conflit idéologique alors
c'est plus le capitalisme contre le
socialisme aujourd'hui c'est une forme
de ces la souveraineté contre le
mondialisme
c est lors la souveraineté sous tous ses
aspects c'est la souveraineté politique
la souveraineté diplomatique mais un
souveraineté économique également la
russie a évolué aujourd'hui la situation
là la vision qu'ont les dirigeants
russes n'a plus grand chose à voir avec
celle qu'on a pu connaître dans les
années 90 avec avec helsinn donc
aujourd'hui ce que pense que c'est la
russie montre le mauvais exemple à
l'europe qui elle est sur des bases
idéologiques et sur un projet qui est
complètement différent c'est à dire là
le fait de passer au delà des nations
pour construire quelque chose d'autre
merci
rémy vous restez avec nous on va bien
sûr continuer à évoquer ces cérémonies
se défiler et ce jour si particulier
avec vous mais avant cela le président
vladimir poutine a prononcé un discours
en ouverture de ce défilé l'a rendu
hommage aux soldats de la grande guerre
patriotique qui a observé une minute de
silence est le président a ensuite
rappelé que la russie continuer le
combat contre ce qui menaçait ses
intérêts on en parlait justement à tout
à l'heure à écouter la lumière poutine
l'histoire nous oblige à tirer des
conclusions à tirer des leçons mais nous
constatons que tous ne sont pas prêts à
tirer cette conclusion et qui veulent en
à nouveau défendre cette idéologie on
voit la résurgence de d'extrémistes et
d'adeptes de cette idéologie de volonté
voit cette volonté de réécrire
l'histoire et les centaines de milliers
de morts sont ignorés par ce genre
aujourd'hui on sait que chaque famille
garde la mémoire de ceux qui sont ici
ont combattu la russie continue à
défendre le droit international et nous
continuerons à défendre en même temps il
ose un terreau nos intérêts nationaux
gilles rémy vous êtes une nouvelle fois
avec nous sur rt tranche je rappelle que
vous êtes un homme d'affaires et que
vous avez vécu longtemps en russie vous
avez écouté avec nous le président
vladimir poutine qui parlait du du
souvenir qui parlait des vétérans de
l'hommage que l'on devait rendre aux
vétérans la notion de souvenirs elle est
importantes en russie oui la notion
souvenirs et est importante non
seulement parce que le il s'agit comme
on l'a dit d'un du monde une guerre est
exceptionnel dans sa dans son ampleur
dans ce leurre mais également parce que
les russes ont un sens aigü l'histoire
c'est à dire que là on n'a pas assisté à
une à une destruction de l'histoire la
et écoute il a réussi à faire quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel c'est à dire
une forme de saclay tismée de et
d'intégrer un roman national ce que nous
l'avions d'ailleurs connu et qui va de
des tsars des empereurs en passant par
par la période soviétique le rôle de
staline etc qui est une analyse qui est
aussi critique sur le sur un cynisme
mais qui intègre toutes les époques et
toutes les générations en ce qui
concerne l'histoire contemporaine dans
un passé un passé et un passé pour avoir
un avenir commun donc les livres
d'histoire des écoles russes sont des
livres qui ressemble un petit peu à ceux
des années soixante ou soixante dix en
france c'est à dire qu'on a eu lieu à
rome au jeu reprend le terme un roman
national qui intègre toutes les époques
et qui donne effectivement une
profondeur historique que l'argent ne
sera la population russe qui est un peu
différent le en occident et en france
particulièrement
gilles rémy on a suivi ensemble sur les
antennes d'ayrté france ce matin entre
9h et 10h cet immense défilé militaire
qui est le lieu je le rappelle sur la
place rouge comme tous les ans le 9 mai
sauf l'année dernière pour raisons
sanitaires on était donc à moscou mais
la russie c'est un pays excessivement
grand est ce que vous savez ce qui se
passe ce jour là dans les autres villes
du pays
oui c'est ce qui se passe il se passe
que dans chaque lot chaque village dans
chaque ville de russie aujourd'hui c'est
à
c'est un c'est un grand jour et les gens
sont dans la rue et les gens y vont au
monument aux morts
et puis les gens dans chaque famille il
y a les familles se retrouvent et c'est
un repas repas de fête et de souvenirs
est ce assez
on n'a pas la même si beau ce trou et
parfois différent du pays profond c'est
certainement une des choses qui est un
lieu partagé aujourd'hui c'est la
commémoration du 9 mai dans toute la
russie
comme je disais aussi dans une grande
partie de l'ex union soviétique
on a parlé tout à l'heure de la parade
des immortels
cette parade ou où justement les les
rues stand des panneaux avec des photos
de leurs ancêtres des cd ou qui ont subi
cette seconde guerre mondiale ça aussi
cette parade des immortels c'est un
symbole est ce que vous avez à vous avez
assisté vous oui j'ai participé à
plusieurs reprises et je pense était là
problème la première ou la deuxième dont
vous imaginez dans dans moscou sur la
rue tverskaïa où ont défilé les chars
tout à l'heure vous avez après la parade
militaire
des milliers des centaines de milliers
de gens qui se réunissent spontanément
on n'est pas dans une une démonstration
enfin dans des manifestations du 1er mai
soviétique où il y avait par entreprise
a un contingent qu'ils étaient
déterminés là les gens viennent et ne
viennent pas mais les gens viennent et
est ce qui est très très très marquant
c'est effectivement c'est que vous avez
toutes les générations
toutes les générations et les enfants et
les enfants porteurs de des photos des
portraits de leur arrière grand père
c'est quelque chose de très le 13
novembre et sera l'ami tout à l'heure
ses traits marquants et surtout pour
nous français parce que on a en a le
sentiment d'avoir perdu cette capacité à
de 2,2 de nous réunir ensemble pour pour
communaux et toutes générations
confondues et des sas et le groupe à on
parlait tout à l'heure de effectivement
dû de l'histoire du sens de l'histoire
c'est cet insigne un signe très très
très fort et je rappelle cette
initiative delà du bataillon des
immortels est une
10 au départ une initiative privée qui
est médias qui correspondait soixante
dix ans après qui correspond encore est
belle et plus que jamais à ce que
ressentent les russes c'est à dire une
grande fierté et pour leur histoire
nationale
on le disait un peu de diplomate et peu
de chefs d'état étrangers on assistait
ce à se défier comment peut on peut
l'expliquer raisons sanitaires
diplomatique les deux je crois qu'il ya
un peu les deux la pandémie justifie
beaucoup de choses l'année dernière on
avait on avait beaucoup espéré on
attendait la musique du président du
président français ça ne s'est pas fait
pour principalement pour des raisons des
raisons sanitaires aujourd'hui il n'y
avait qu'un seul président étranger
était président entre harmonies faut
conclut tome est en carbone du
tadjikistan cela étant ce n'est pas ça
ne suffit pas que la russie soit isolé
comme je le disais delà de l'asie de
l'afrique ou td des anciens des anciens
pays
j'aurais quand même dire un petit mot
quand même ce qui n'est pas ce par
rapport au discours de de poutine et sur
la résurgence d'idéologie avait je pense
qu'il avait carrément tête ce qui se
passe en ukraine ce qui est très
douloureux non seulement pour les
ukrainiens mais pour les russes c'est se
laisser faire du régime au pouvoir en
ukraine en verre ce qui est la
résurgence de teint d'une collaboration
et d'asie j'étais très très choqué de
voir que la dernière manifestation néo
nazis en faveur du régiment des waffen
ss galicie qui a eu lieu à kiev ya
quinze jours n'a pas du tout été évoquée
par là par la presse heure française
l'occidentale en général parce que ça
gêne parce que là elle à l'ukraine et
est notre alliée dans une d'engins dans
un combat pour affaiblir la la la russie
c'est un calcul stupide à mon sens c'est
mais on ne doit pas laisser passer les
choses comme ça tous les russes savent
très bien ça passe dans les dents les
dans les journaux télévisés ce qui se
passe en ukraine alors c'est pas là
le pays entier qui risque de tomber dans
la dans un néo nazisme mais c'est
insupportable insupportable que des
monument sera érigé à d'anciens
collaborateurs nazis
et puis c'est insupportable que par
exemple le sixième site et 16e
anniversaire du massacre de dessin qu'en
plus de 40 personnes ont été brûlées
vives à la maison des syndicats où elle
a dit nations étrangères la ligne à sion
et l'agneau parti en ukraine et en
russie
et donc ces seules deux poids deux
mesures qui qui est assez choquant et je
pense que c'était ça qui nous fait qu'il
fallait voir aussi dans la résurgence de
ce d'idéologie néo nazi antisémite dont
par des comptines dans son discours
gilles rémy j'aimerais revenir avec vous
sur cette journée du 9 mai sur ce sur ce
défilé sur ces célébrations
vous qui avez vécu longtemps en russie
vous avez également été décoré de
l'ordre de l'amitié par vladimir poutine
il ya quatre ans maintenant on en
parlait avec jean de gliniasty tout à
l'heure lui qui était ambassadeur il
ressentait justement cette volonté des
russes de vouloir nouer des relations
avec la france
est ce que c'est ce que vous avez
ressenti vous aussi quand vous étiez sur
place
ah oui bien sûr c'est ça c'est une
constante de la 2d russe du peuple russe
s'est installée la france c'est le sait
le pays c'est le pays le plus aimé à
l'étranger c'est pour des raisons de
culture d'histoire là la france a aidé à
admirer je dirais que l'évolution c'est
que peut-être que là nous avons été
admirés tête au delà de ce que nous
pouvions être et que aujourd'hui les
russes
qu'ils connaissent mieux la france que
les français ne connaissent la russie
aujourd'hui sont terriblement déçue
déçue par quand ils viennent en visite
en france par là peut-être la saleté de
paris mais également par l'attitude
qu'ils ont sur sur l'avenir l'avenir de
notre pays
je suis très très très bien l'actualité
l'actualité française et il y as est cet
attachement qu'ils ont à la france fait
que certainement la russie est un des
prix ils souffrent plus de nous de notre
difficulté pour lui jeremy vous restez
avec nous bien entendu on va continuer
de commenter cette cérémonie du 9 mai
avec vous juste avant en ce jour de
mémoire les russes
elles se souviennent des hommes qui se
sont distingués au cours des événements
de la seconde guerre mondiale et nicolas
et qui sait liow était de ceux là
parfois surnommé el chine la russie la
sauver à des allemands 218 juive
biélorusse en les guidant sur 1500 km
pour leur faire rejoindre les troupes
soviétiques à l'est il a été reconnu
juste parmi les nations à titre posthume
par israël au regard des voiliers ses
stratèges -14 renier les jmj
[Musique]
bon
notre espèce
il y avait 35 enfants de 2 à 14 ans il y
avait des vieillards des personnes loin
d'être en bonne santé
non non non c'est au certains étaient
portés en civière d'autres sur un cheval
donné par le début les gens étaient
dénudés a failli marcher la nuit
on marchait 30 40 km pendant la nuit
parfois peut-être plus nos le danger
était énorme
nous avons plusieurs fois été attaquée
par les allemands euros soudain on a
entendu des coups de feu des tirs dans
notre direction tout le monde s'est
dispersé
c'est à ces balles et il a tout à coup
j'ai vu qu'il n'y avait personne près de
moi et a nié je ne savais pas quoi faire
ou courir chien heureusement ma soeur
m'a vu je ne sais pas comment elle m'a
pris par la main et nous nous sommes mis
à courir
il s'est avéré que bas loin de l'endroit
où nous étions de la route forestière
il y avait des allemands bnd
des candidats qu'ils ont entendu des
coups ils ont ouvert le feu sans savoir
ce qui se passait mais comme beaucoup de
personnes attablées ses bouquets et
bouira les frères un groupe d'allemands
de lituaniens est venu les toffes ça et
la chaleur est ce qu'on appelle la
première action a commencé dès le matin
pendant la journée jusqu'au soir à nice
ils ont cherché des juifs dans les
maisons il envoyait dans les rues ils
les abattent et comme dn1 de rochette
est à la deuxième action a duré trois
jours
[Musique]
c'est une dans un fossé s'était enfoncé
très profond abbaoui couler nous étions
assis dans l'eau comme ça tu n'existes
pas ces trois jours nous entendions des
gens courir boom 20 tirs aïe
quelqu'un qui tombe agnac ils ont ouvert
le fossé de nos voisins ayant lancé une
grenade
il y avait de tels hurlements des cris
des cris je m'en souviens nogué une
jeune fille ait eu les jambes arrachées
[Musique]
nous avions avec nous une petite fille
elle avait peut-être trois ans et à la
flore et tout le temps l'ennemi quand
nous passions près de la rivière c'était
un endroit dangereux à papa ce même et
instable avait des allemands aux
alentours
elle aurait aussi tout le monde a
commencé à dire nous allons tous mourir
à cause d'elle il faut la noyée et on a
d'autres abris et hongrie
le père a dit à sa femme vas-y toi fais
le tu fais le toi même je ne peux pas et
toi non plus c'est qui c'est l'offre aux
harkis celle yoff a su qu'il voulait
noyer la fille katia quand appris
qu'être gay roach coup holwadag chaud on
s'est approché l'a prise dans ses bras
et l'a consolé je ne sais pas comment
ils ont ponctué ce qui en fait il l'a
porté pendant plusieurs semaines dans
ses bras
au lieu de ses parents oui au lieu de
ses parents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rt france il est 11h 20 on vous le
disait dispositif exceptionnel
aujourd'hui pour vous faire vivre comme
si vous étés est cette grande journée de
célébrations en l'honneur de la victoire
lors de la seconde guerre mondiale et
justement on part tout de suite
direction moscou ou plutôt on retourne
direction est ce que vous retrouvez à
notre envoyé spécial doha abdelrazik
doha vous êtes si ma culture est bonne
vous êtes descendus
vous êtes descendus de votre toit et
vous êtes actuellement sur la place
rouge racontez-nous ce qui se passe en
ce moment autour de vous
tout à fait je suis descendu de mon 17e
étage perché tout en haut dans le ciel
et maintenant on est venu de la voix la
place rouge qui est l'entrée de la place
rouge qui est juste derrière moi et j'ai
avec moi une charmante invités que l'on
connaît un puisque habitués de rt france
on a l'occasion de vous voilà de vous
appeler de vous demander un petit peu
vos analyses carim béchir gologo
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou
je suis ravi de vous rencontrer en chair
et en os merci demain voilà gawker
c'était très important pour nous de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui car vous connaissez
très bien la russie ça fait plus de
vingt ans que vous êtes installés ici et
alors le sentiment que moi j'ai eu en
arrivant à moscou il ya quelques jours
c'est un sentiment de fierté dans cette
dans ce pays avec tous ces drapeaux
rouges
le jour de la victoire la grande guerre
patriotique qu'est ce que cela
représente pour les ressorts en effet ce
qui marque énorme
c'est cette ce culte du passé mais dans
le bon sens du thème du terme parce
qu'ils comprennent parfaitement qu'en
fait l'avenir d'un pays se construit
dans la mesure où vous arrivez à
intégrer toutes les faces différentes de
votre histoire nationale et en ce sens
là la grande guerre patriotique et quand
même coûté la vie à 27
des soldats soviétiques c'est quand même
un chiffre qui montre l'ampleur en fait
delachaux et la victoire est la victoire
de tout un peuple
donc ça fait partie de ces symboles qui
unissent les pays et le 9 mai en russie
est un symbole justement puisque neuf
mais pas lui puisque comme on le sait
quand l'acte de capitulation de
l'allemagne est entré en vigueur il
était déjà une heure du matin me suis
donc voilà le 9 mai est célébré et a été
célébré sans interruption sauf au début
des années 90 ce qui montre aussi la
symbolique en fait de cette de cette
victoire puisque justement dans les
années 90 après la chute de l'union
soviétique où le pays était quand même
très affaibli politiquement où il y
avait une forte implication imprégnation
américaine ici étrangement le 9 mai
n'était plus célébrer ce retour marque
en fait aussi ce retour de la russie et
qui s'inscrit dans le temps et qui
continue donc c'est très très important
que quelles que soient les situations
cette fête célébrée
c'est un véritable devoir de mémoire en
fait voilà que que fait la russie qui
est quelque chose de très important se
souvenir son passé pour pouvoir
peut-être se projeter vers l'avenir se
rappeler du sacrifice aussi comme vous
l'avez dit un de ces personnes ces
victimes ont dit que toutes les familles
soviétique puisque l'union et de l'union
soviétique à l'époque voilà c'était pas
seulement la russie mais ont perdu au
moins un membre
ils ont été touchés vraiment en plein
coeur par cette guerre est ce que
finalement cette mémoire historique est
toujours vivante
cette mémoire et soler qui est toujours
vivante effectivement toutes les
familles en fête en russie et dans tout
l'espace un peu soviétique aujourd'hui
ont été touchés par par cette guerre
puisque c'était réellement pourquoi on
l'appelle pas simplement à seconde
guerre mondiale en russie et dans
l'espace possible mais sale guerre
patriotique parce que c'est vraiment la
gueule d'un peuple
du qui a soutenu son arme est donc il un
soulèvement patriotique et on en
retrouve cette mort vivante et le
régiment est mortel a été pendant
quelques années le symbole justement de
cette vente il est extrêmement dommage
que cette année il n'est pas dessus
être réalisée par ce qui permet
d'entretenir ce lien entre les
générations de faire ce lien entre le
passé et l'avenir
et comme l'a rappelé le président
poutine dans son discours ce matin
d'ailleurs les dangers qui existaient à
l'époque commencent à resurgir
aujourd'hui et donc il est important de
tirer des leçons et lorsque l'on voit
sur jiwa et mortelle six dernières
années qu'ils marchaient dans les rues
de moscou et dans d'autres villes de
russie et en europe
on comprenait l'ampleur aussi des
personnes qui ont été victimes de cette
guerre et ça peut faire aussi réfléchir
pour éviter que ça se reproduise
vous parliez de deux de ces célébrations
du 9 mai 45 que l'on commémore
aujourd'hui le jour de la victoire c'est
d'ailleurs sur la place rouge que les
premiers soldats ont battu le pavé
voilà on célébrant est la défaite du
troisième reich commencent à évoluer au
fil du temps est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
voilà ces célébrations sont encore plus
importantes plus grandiose plus
majestueuse que les années précédentes
par exemple parce que ça va crescendo
aisée je pense pas que ça
la chaîne hbo je pense que ça se
différencient et c'est naturel je pense
qu'en matière d'émotions dans les
premières années au contraire d'une
motion devait être encore plus forte
puisque vous aviez les personnes qui ont
vécu ça nous rajeunit
vous aviez leurs enfants vous avez tout
est à la fois situer cette énergie qui
se dégageait parce que s'il ya eu
énormément nombre de morts mais
énormément de personnes qui ont été
blessées les personnes qui ont été
handicapées mais indépendamment de ça il
y avait une énergie à son phénoménal qui
se dégageait de cette génération pour
construire un pays et c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui a sorti complètement l'union
soviétique de la guerre et qui a permis
de faire un bond en avant seulement
phénoménal quand on voit les
réalisations scientifiques industriels
dans les années 60 quand on sait comment
le pays a été détruit lors de son coeur
c'est un moment que nomena et c'est
grâce à cette génération de personnes
qui ont fait la guerre donc je pense
simplement c'est différent maintenant
nous vivons dans une configuration qui
est plus tranquille
nous sommes un petit peu apaisées
peut-être un petit peu trop
c'est pour ça qu'il est d'autant plus
important de garder ses symboles de
garder ce lien de penser à ces personnes
qui ont défendu leur patrie pour
comprendre qu' il ya plein de façons
défendre sa patrie comme il ya plein de
façons car la guêpe uniquement avec les
temps qui on le voit aujourd'hui
donc il est important de préserver ses
valeurs de préserver sa culture tout en
s'ouvrant à celle des autres mais en
défendant aussi la sienne et je pense
que c'est cet équilibre qui essaye de
trouver la russie c'est à dire ne pas
s'enfermer
oui mais mettre en valeur ce qui fait
qu'elle n'ait la russie et le l'effet du
9 mai et cette énergie que l'on trouve
lors de six des neuf 9 et 12
l'immortel ça contribue en fait
justement à cette force intérieure de la
population russe qui perpétue dans
d'autres conditions avec un contexte qui
est
errant qui a salle d'autres besoins et
qui perpétue en fait ce combat des
générations d'un peuple qui aime son
pays et qui montrent sexuellement
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
le jour de la victoire
voilà est encore plus important de la
fête nationale russe oui puisque le
problème soulevé de la fête nationale
russe et qu' il ya eu la période
soviétique qui avait établi son
calendrier de fête pour des rede pour
des raisons idéologiques évidente a
lâché dans ce métier qu'il a fallu
réinventer un petit peu les têtes
nationale donc elles ne sont pas entrées
si vous voulez dans la culture nationale
réelle du pays
ce sont des fêtes officielles j'en ai
fait institutionnels ne sont pas des
fêtes populaires
le 9 mai et la fête de la russie la fête
du peuple russe a en fait de la nation
puisque ça fait la nation pour qu'un pas
que des gars nation il a besoin de se
construire s'unifier autour des symboles
et le 9 mai est justement cette fête de
la nation russe clinique en tout cas
merci beaucoup et bonne fête alors
puisque voilà on se félicite ici en
terre c'est ce jour de la victoire
bonne fête à nous y sommes pas bien
voilà j'ai essayé je suis pas arrivé la
preuve quelques petit monospace ibach sz
massive à karine les chaînes de lefaux
merci voilà d'avoir été avec nous ici en
direct à quelques mètres de la place
rouge pour nous raconter un petit peu
voilà ce que représente donc ce jour de
la victoire ici pour la russie pierre
c'est à vous on va se retrouver dans
quelques instants avec la deuxième
invitée
bon ben si vous mettez au russe moi
aussi alors as passive à doha et merci
également à karine bcgo locaux qui était
avec vous sur la place rouge de à moscou
on revient ici en france dans les cieux
d'ayrté france et à paris nous sommes
toujours avec notre invité
excusez-moi j'ai perdu votre nom gilles
rémy excusez-moi gilles rémy vous vous
êtes toujours avec nous voilà en direct
de paris
vous avez entendu ce qui s'est dit sur
cette place rouge à moscou on parlait
juste avant des relations franco-russes
vous qu'il y avait longtemps vécu en
russie qui avaient beaucoup échangé avec
les russes
racontez nous un petit peu qu'elle était
le genre de relation que vous entretenez
avec avec nos amis russes
je le prendrais pour passer parce que je
suis toujours un acteur la coopération
économique entre les deux pays
leleu nous avons vécu au cours des 10 15
dernières années de très très très grand
moment en termes de coopération que ce
soit dans le secteur nucléaire et que ce
soit souvenez vous aussi dans le secteur
de la défense ces fameux mistral qui ont
été un exemple extraordinaire de
coopération industrielle militaire et
politique et je crois que la rupture
effectivement il ya eu un moment une
étape extrêmement négative qui était qui
a été passé quand le président hollande
a décidé de ne pas livrer les bateaux
qui étaient construits qui avait été
payée et de ne pas les livrer alors que
juridiquement et les mêmes
diplomatiquement rien ne nous obligeait
à renoncer à ce contrat puisqu'il avait
été signé avant les sanctions
européennes
suite au rattachement de
la crimée à la russie à partir de ce
moment là effectivement il ya eu une
rupture une perte de confiance puisque
aussi s'agissait il n'y a pas de
précédent à ce genre de renonciation
aujourd'hui la coopération continue et
les mêmes importante à français est un
des principaux investisseurs occidentaux
en russie le premier employé employeur
étranger et donc nous avons aujourd'hui
des entreprises la plupart des
entreprises du cac 40 mais aussi des
centaines d'entreprises qui sont
présentes à moscou et je dois dire que
le rôle joué par par les entreprises
dans la relation bilatérale est
extrêmement important on avait connu la
halle et le monde des affaires à
l'époque soviétique
les échanges étaient relativement
limitées et il y avait c'était plutôt
chez les politiques qu'il y avait une
expertise de la russie jeu d'enchères
partis politiques
il y avait des gens qui connaissaient
très très très bien et qu'ils avaient
des contacts personnels avec des des
personnalités soviétiques et russes
aujourd'hui je dirais que nous avons un
affaiblissement terrible de la
connaissance réelle de ce qu'est la
russie
dans le monde politique français et
heureusement heureusement la le mode
économique très très présent en russie à
mathias est ce ce dialogue et d'échangé
on se souvient à la mort de jacques
chirac
vladimir poutine penney
de la mort de l'ancien président
français les deux hommes s'entendaient
bien les deux hommes s'étaient vus
plusieurs fois vladimir poutine avait
même dit qu'ils avaient été
impressionnés par la culture du
président français est ce que justement
à l'époque de jacques chirac
on a vécu une hégémonie des relations
franco russes oui on a vécu on était
dans une période de très bonne entente
de très bonne compréhension
là il faut dire que la politique
américaine et européenne était et est
beaucoup plus modérée qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui donc le contexte était quand
même beaucoup plus favorable laissée
d'une marge de manoeuvre plus importante
il faut quand même souligner que dans il
ya une forme de continuité avec la
présidence sarkozy qui était
certainement les 6,5 années ont été
marquées par de très grandes avancées
dans le domaine de la coopération
économique
il y avait pris à l'époque de sarkozy
souvenons nous que le le le prédire que
poutine n'était pas d'aidé pas président
il était premier ministre et sans son
interlocuteur de travail était françois
fillon et est donc ce qui a amené les
deux hommes d'ailleurs très bien se
connaître et à travailler des dossiers
d'une manière très approfondie et ces
années ont été marquées et effectivement
la symbolique sera la décision française
de coopérer pour la première fois à
cette échelle dans le secteur de la
coopération militaro industriel en
construisant les mistral sur les
chantiers navals de saint nazaire
donc on a eu effectivement dans l'art
dans la la prolongation dans l'impulsion
qui avait été donnée par par jacques
chirac
on a eu jusqu'à la présidence et
hollande d année faste en termes de
coopération
merci beaucoup jérémy d'avoir été avec
nous tout au long de cette matinée pour
commentaires ont semblé analyser cette
76ème cérémonie du jeu
au cours de la victoire merci beaucoup à
vous on part tout de suite on repart
tout de suite direction la place rouge à
moscou retrouver notre envoyé spécial
dorabella rasic doha une nouvelle fois
vous n'êtes pas tout seul non je ne suis
pas tout seul cette fois ci je suis
accompagné par monsieur olivier belote
responsables associatifs et candidat aux
élections consulaires
bonjour ravi de vous rencontrer ravi de
venir vous voir ici en russie puisque
alors on a on a discuté avec madame
deschênes molko il ya peu de temps vous
aussi ça fait longtemps que vous êtes là
ça fait déjà 20 ans sa fédération à bord
voilà vingt ans que vous êtes là vingt
ans que vous assistez à ces célébrations
du 9 mai 45
qu'est-ce que cela voilà évoque chez
vous qu'est ce que vous ressentez
très fort une très forte émotion à
chaque fois bon là bien sûr à cause du
covili a plus le défilé populaire des
immortels mais
le souvenir de la guerre est très vivace
chez les russes comme je vous le disais
je m'occupe un petit peu de normandie
niemen ce cas des îles françaises des
français libres qui est venu combattre à
côté de l'armée rouge
et à chaque fois je suis en contact avec
les écoles notamment je suis frappé par
la ferveur qu'ils ont ils n'oublient pas
que les français sont venus se battre à
leur côté avant même la victoire de
stalingrad et donc voilà ça on transfère
n'est toujours choyé de la ce niveau là
et bien sûr nous aussi on a la même le
même respect pour le nos anciens on sent
beaucoup de patriotisme chez les russes
russie lit eux
ni on n'a pas le même sentiment en
france est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que le patriotisme russe et texas et
seraient exacerbés par rapport à la
france
je ne sais pas c'est vrai que du côté
russe
ils ont sans doute l'impression d'être
parfois un peu encerclé par l'otan et
ses mai
je dirais que le patriotisme c'est
quelque chose d'important et de base
pour tous les peuples je veux dire on
peut pas construire sur du sable
donc il est évident qu'il faut avoir des
bases et donc enseigner aux enfants
l'amour de leur patrie de leur langue
chaque pays fait la même chose
c'est ce qu'on appelle des peuples
souverains et donc je pense que le
patriotisme on peut le voir évidemment
de façon exacerbée aime ça c'est des
gens qui te voit de l'extérieur où tous
les français que j'ai connu en 20 ans
qui sont venus ici des amis etc
à chaque fois ils sont tous agréablement
surpris par l'accueil des russes est
viré on peut pas considérer que les
russes sont agressifs ou belliqueux le
devoir de mémoire ça c'est important
aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr bien sûr que je lui ai dit
j'ai été aussi longtemps responsable
une association de parents d'élèves est
donc évidemment il faut que les enfants
connaissent les choses parce que c'est
bien beau nous on a parfois une approche
un peu moins chronologique par exemple
de l'enseignement
mais les bases c'est quand même de
connaître de connaître ensuite les
enfants quand ils grandissent et font
des opinions il droit d'avoir toutes
opinions mais il faut donner les bases
et donc le devoir de mémoire bien sûr
c'est la base c'est quand je suis venu
en russie j'ai vu les derniers vétérans
normandie niemen nous quitte et
malheureusement côté français il reste
encore deux vétérans russes puisqu'il
était plus jeune et mécaniciens donc ça
toujours là mais je vois que
la ferveur et la même et donc ça c'est
intéressant parce que ça montre que il
n'oublie pas voilà à nous de ne pas
oublier non plus d'être à la hauteur de
leurs intérêts et justement l'union
soviétique a payé un lourd tribut
pendant cette seconde guerre mondiale
plus précisément entre le début de
l'invasion par l'allemagne le 21 22 juin
1941 jusqu'au 9 mai 1945 on parle de
plus de 27 millions de deux victimes
toutes les familles ont été touchées par
cette guerre terrible
finalement est-ce que c'est dans la
douleur que là qu'on tire cette force en
fait de pouvoir continuer de relever la
tête
oui oui tout à fait c'est on se rend pas
bien compte en europe du de la charge
émotionnelle car présenté cette guerre
quand je suis venu par exemple il ya
vingt ans je pensais aussi comme
beaucoup de français que les américains
avaient joué un rôle prépondérant dans
l'alliance des alliés bien sûr et leur
rôle n'est pas nier mais
les rues sont et 1
pour un incroyable
et tellement d'histoires tellement
d'anecdotes il n'oublie pas aucune
famille russe n'oublie mais en france
aussi je vois que tu aimes la même chose
et puis dans tous les pays et qui ont
été touchés par la guerre je sens qu'il
ya une regain d'intérêt et c'est bien
c'est juste ne pas oublier dans nos
anciens est ce qu'ils ont fait pour que
nous soyons libres est ce que vous
regrettez le fait qu' il n'est pas comme
en france en france la fête nationale au
14 juillet on peut assister justement
voir les défilés militaires ici pour des
raisons de sécurité peut être le public
n'est pas très proche de la place rouge
mais on voit quand même dans les yeux
des enfants que c'est quelque chose de
magique nous on a eu ce matin l'occasion
vraiment d'être au coeur de l'événement
est ce que vous aimeriez voilà que nous
un futur proche peut-être que les gens
se voient là soient présents ici autour
de cette place vous rassure c'est à
cause du coc vide puisque avant
tout était accessible donc maintenant
c'est plus compliqué voilà mes notamment
quand il ya le défilé des immortels qui
descendent l'avenue de versailles à 1
on est vraiment pris par l'ambiance et
chacun apporte un portrait d'un proche
c'est vraiment très émouvant donc et
ensuite ça continue de l'autre côté par
le court donc vous inquiétez pas c'est
juste temporaire je pense et je ne sais
pas ce qu'il en sera dans vingt ans mais
je ne vois pas du tout de baisse de
l'intérêt du peuple du 13e régiment le
défilé du régiment des immortels on sent
tout le poids du sacrifice en fait le
soldat russe soviétique
c'était un soldat voilà qui n'avait peur
de rien c'est peut-être pour ça aussi
que aujourd'hui on veut commémorer la
mémoire de ceux qui ont disparu
on l'a vu dans le métro de moscou même
il y a des fresques avec les soldats il
y a aussi ses rames de métro qui ont été
décorés l'occasion tout à fait oui mais
en plus les russes ont le sentiment
d'avoir été trahis par hitler bien sûr
ils s'attendaient oui je sais que mon
année green attaque mais c'est comme
l'invasion napoléonienne dont on vient
que je fais c'est le bicentenaire donne
habituellement napoléon justement vous
me parlez de napoléon on parle du caire
pourquoi à chaque fois que quelqu'un a
essayé d'envahir la russie finalement
pas voilà
je pense était la même erreur
stratégique c'est-à-dire l'espace russe
c'est tellement grand napoléon a réussi
arrive jusqu'à jusqu'à moscou c'était
déjà énorme pour l'époque mais bien sûr
le de s'arrêter à saint pétersbourg il
n'a pas pu aller jusque là bas et puis
si les sous-estimer l'hiver russe et dès
qu il a fait un temps hivernal
insupportable c'était la déroute est
claire a fait un peu la même erreur
vouloir combattre sur deux fronts
il a été d'abord en angleterre ensuite
il s'est retourné sur la russie mais
trop tard
en pris par d'autres théâtres et donc
ici ça s'est joué à très peu les
allemands étaient en haut de cette
avenue de versailles a en décembre 41
donc j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller là bas
et on se souvient encore de l'endroit où
les derniers les premières des dernières
patrouilles allemandes ont pu approcher
des lignes de métro qui de tramway qui a
mené jusqu'au centre de moscou
quand ils sont passés très près très
près de la défaite totale même si elle
évacuer beaucoup d' usine beaucoup de
choses importants dont le mausolée de
lénine etc ils ont jamais oublier ce
choc donc mais par contre je dirais pas
qu'ils en veulent aux allemands par
exemple ni et aux français à cause de
napoléon il adore napoléon si les a fait
rentrer quelque part dans l'histoire
serait bien sûr voilà il ya vraiment une
passion pour l'histoire mais nous on est
on est ravis de leur intérêt pour
l'histoire napoléonienne aussi bien sûr
quand le français a laissé voilà une
admiration commune on va dire en tout
cas la première voilà ça nous rapproche
car il ya beaucoup de choses qui les
rapprochent
évidemment la russie à la france en tout
cas merci beaucoup voilà d'avoir de nous
avoir accordé ces quelques mots à vous
aussi je me souhaite une très bonne fête
ces deux mêmes mois en russe se passe
mais comme voilà voilà bien un nouveau
lourd russe peut-être que vous
vous réussir à la fin de cette édition
spéciale à parler en tout cas mieux que
loi russe
on va se retrouver dans peu de temps
avec à notre troisième invité merci
beaucoup d'aura abdelrazik je ne
m'étendrai pas sur ce mot rue st je
préfère à rester aux français merci en
tout cas à vous d'avoir participé à
cette cérémonie du 9 mai à moscou je le
rappelle jour de la victoire on referme
cette édition spéciale merci également à
tous nos envoyés spéciaux et
correspondants on verra goffman comme
terreau et mona mode alors merci aux
équipes à paris et à moscou et puis
surtout un grand merci à vous d'avoir
suivi cette grande journée de
célébration l'information continue tu
restais france à midi vous serez en
compagnie admirable bendjaballah
jean-pierre très bonne journée avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ait des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative au
sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était les gens quittent